Dann herzlich willkommen zu Alternativlos, die Folge Nr. 18.
Wir wollen euch heute mit euch über den Untergang reden.
Über den Untergang? Nein, überall ist Nacht im Untergang. Und bei uns zu Gast heute ist Rob Gondheim, mit dem ich zusammen auf dem krass-communication-camp einen Vortrag gemacht hab über transition Telekom. Hallo Rob.
Hallo.
Und wir wollen uns heute darüber unterhalten, zum einen was liegt denn so alles vor uns mit solchen Sachen wie Peak Oil und endenden Ressourcen und Finanzkrisen und zum anderen wollen wir auch ein bisschen darüber reden, was wir denn so als Hacker oder als Leute, die Technologie interessiert sind, tun können, um dafür zu sagen, dass wir auch hinterher noch telefonieren und unseren Porn runterladen können.
Und wieso das überhaupt ein Problem ist?
Wieso es ein Problem ist, also warum wir nicht davon ausgehen können, dass unser Google-Mail auch irgendwie in fünf Jahren noch problemlos da sein wird. Das sind heute so ein bisschen die Themen. Ja, und dann fangen wir noch ein bisschen an.
Ja, also die erste Überlegung bei vielen Leuten, die sich mit dem Thema beschäftigen, ist Peak Oil. Und darunter versteht man eine These aus den 70ern ursprünglich, bei der es heißt, dass das Öl der Welt endlich ist und dass es zu irgendeinem Zeitpunkt der Punkt überschritten ist, wo die Preise für das Fördern stabil sind oder nach unten gehen. Ab da ist der Punkt überschritten, wo Öl einfach immer nur noch teurer wird.
Peak Oil ist nicht aus den 70ern. Peak Oil ist noch von vorher aus den 50ern, wenn ich es richtig habe.
Ich habe 72 gehört, aber das kann sein, dass es vorher auch schon was gab.
Es ist die Vorhersage der Oil Peak in den Vereinigten Staaten.
Der Oil Peak war aus den 70ern. Ich habe gelesen, dass es ursprünglich von einem Typen kam, der Verbindung zu der Atommafia hatte. Das heißt, die Leute, die das Papier bezahlt haben, in dem ursprünglich das vorhergesagt wurde, waren die Leute, die gerne Atomkraftwerke bauen wollten. Daher ist das am Anfang diskreditiert worden. Und die Leute wollten das eigentlich auch nicht glauben. Die Idee, dass das Öl irgendwann alle ist, da will ja auch niemand wirklich drüber nachdenken. Aber es zeigt sich eben in den Statistiken.
Die Ölfirmen wissen das schon richtig lange und agieren auch schon richtig lange danach. Es wird schon echt lange keine Raffinerien mehr gebaut. Die maximale Fördermenge ist erreicht. Das heißt, die Hälfte der Öl ist noch in der Erde, aber die Geologie hat Eigenschaften, die dafür sorgt, dass es nicht wie eine Flasche ist, die man leerkippt und dann irgendwann kommt nichts mehr raus. Sondern es ist so eine Kurve. Man kriegt pro Jahr immer mehr Öl aus einer Quelle und irgendwann erreicht man eine maximale Menge. Und dann, eigentlich gleich danach, kriegt man jedes Jahr weniger. Und als Aggregat von allen Quellen zusammen hat auch die ganze Erde so eine Kurve, wo irgendwann die maximale Fördermenge an Öl erreicht worden ist. Und dann geht es danach direkt runter.
Also die Sache wird ja schon länger diskutiert. Und es gibt witzigerweise, genau wie bei den Tabaktoten und bei anderen kontroversen, pseudo-kontroversen Themen, gibt es auch eine gegenposition, die an dieser Stelle die These vertritt, dass Öl eben nicht organisch generiert ist, sondern irgendwie aus dem Gestein kommt und daher unendlich ist. Aber das ist eigentlich genauso diskreditiert wie diese Gegenthese zu, dass vielleicht Tabak doch nicht tödlich ist und so.
Dafür gibt es keinerlei Beweise?
Es gibt keinerlei Beweise. Das wird gerne hochgehalten in den Internet vorn, das werdet ihr wahrscheinlich sehen, wenn ihr nach dem Thema ein bisschen googelt. Aber wissenschaftlich gesehen ist, da gibt es keine Beweise dafür.
Wir sollten kurz nochmal sagen, wenn ihr hier so ein paar Hintergrundgeräusche hört, wir sitzen halt auf dem chaos-communication-camp und da sind so Nebengeräusche von irgendwie Hubschraubern vorbeifahren, Panzern, lustigen Musikfahrzeugen und ähnlich mit total normal. Wir dachten, wir geben euch mal hier so ein kleines bisschen Camp-Atmo mit, damit ihr auch noch was davon habt.
Kann doch sein, dass im Hintergrund mal eine Rakete hochgeschossen wird oder so. Dann müsst ihr mit durch.
Ja, solange wir es noch können.
Wir sollten vielleicht doch kurz erläutern, wie Öl eigentlich aus dem Boden geholt wird. Denn da gibt es auch noch einen interessanten Effekt jetzt nicht bei Öl, sondern bei Erdgas. Also Öl wird aus dem Boden geholt, indem man Wasser in den Boden pumpt und Öl ist eben leichter als Wasser und schwimmt dann oben und kommt raus. Daher kann man sehen, wenn ein Ölfeld anfängt leer zu werden, weil der Wassergehalt in dem Öl, was man oben abschöpft, eben steigt. Anders ist das bei Erdgas. Das ist von sich aus leicht und kommt von alleine hoch. Da gibt es keine Warnung, bevor das Gas alle ist. Das hört halt irgendwann auf, rauszukommen. Daher sind die Voraussagen bei Erdgas immer ein bisschen schwierig. Die entstehen aber ähnlich. Das heißt, man kann im Grunde klar auch von einem Gas-Peak reden. Das ist nicht so, dass wir aus dem Öl-Peak rauskommen, mit dem wir jetzt Gaskraftwerke bauen, was im Moment geschieht, was also keine sonderlich schlaue Taktik ist eigentlich.
Na ja, zumal halt wir Gas sehr dringend brauchen, nicht nur zum Heizen, sondern 90 Prozent des Düngers, den wir zum Essen brauchen, wird aus Gas hergestellt. Das heißt also, der Gaspreis, die Verfügbarkeit von Gas hat einen sehr direkten Einfluss auf die Verfügbarkeit von Nahrungsmitteln.
Dünger ist überhaupt so ein Stichwort, wenn wir bei Peak Oil sind.
Vielleicht sagen wir nochmal...
Nicht vorgreifen, genau.
Genau diese Peak Oil-Sache nochmal ein bisschen genau betrachten, weil es ist ja so eine Geschichte. Vielleicht noch auch doch die Tür zu.
Ach was, das ist hier gerade ein... Man kann hier ein Flugzeug mieten auf den Camp und sich einmal übers Camp fliegen lassen. Und das klingt dann so, wie es jetzt halt klingt.
Okay, also vielleicht sollten wir noch mal kurz ein bisschen was dazu erzählen. Peak Oil war ja vor... Wann haben wir da zuerst drüber geredet? Vor acht Jahren oder so, ne?
Das wir auf dem Kongress drüber geredet haben, war 2005. Also vor sechs Jahren.
Aber es gab auf einem der holländischen Camps auch mal einen Talk dazu, ne?
Das war auch 2005, Sommer 2005.
What the heck, ja. Also vor sechs Jahren haben wir halt ernsthaft angefangen, da mal ein bisschen doller drüber zu reden. Und damals war es halt noch ein ziemliches, so ein, so ein, ja.
Was ist das denn für ein Thema?
Randgruppendingen, ja.
Randgruppendingen. Da war es, the Peak Oil Community war echt noch so eine Art, hat sich angefühlt, als wäre es eine Conspiracy Theory. Und nur wenn man richtig hingeschaut hat, hat man festgestellt, dass es einfach, das ist Wissenschaft und da kann man nachweisen und da gibt es auch einen guten Track Record.
Und das kann man sehen.
Das kann man sehen, das kann man messen. Das ist gar nicht nur, es war gerade zu dem Zeitpunkt halt eine Nachricht, wo die Welt noch überhaupt nicht zuhören wollte. Die international Energy Agency hat in 2005 noch gesagt, ach, ist alles Quatsch, das kommt erst in 2060 und machen Sie sich keine Sorgen. Öl gibt es in Unmengen.
Na ja, und dann...
Und die Umschaltung war dann ziemlich plötzlich. Die international Energy Agency hat dann dieses Jahr für das erste Mal gesagt, ja, Öl gibt es und...
Wie kam das eigentlich, gab es da irgendeinen Auslöser, irgendein, irgendwas rausgekommen, wo sie da nicht mehr irgendwie leugnen konnten oder so? Weil ich fand das ziemlich überraschend, dass die plötzlich eine Kehrtwendung gemacht haben.
Sie haben die Kehrtwendung in einer interessanten Art und Weise gemacht, nämlich unter den sogenannten New Policies. Sie haben halt gesagt, wir haben immer noch genug Öl, da wird es also kein Problem geben.
Ach, das war eher so ein Zukunftsausblick, ja?
Nein, nein, nein, und zwar, ich denke mal, das werden wir noch verlinken, die haben halt einfach sich ein paar schöne Sachen dazugerechnet. Also in deren Weltsicht haben wir halt irgendwie das Öl, wie es halt momentan da ist und die Felder, die momentan produzieren, die nehmen halt auch in deren projektionen relativ deutlich ab. Also da folgt die projektion halt schon den Kurven von diesen.
Nee, deren projektion ist auch für die conventional Oil aus Currently Producing Fields ist viel zu optimistisch. Die gehen davon aus, dass wir in 2025, wir haben hier die Grafik grad vor uns, noch die Hälfte der heutigen Oil, mehr als die Hälfte der heutigen Oil produzieren. Das glaubt weiter niemand.
Also auch aus den konventionellen Feldern, die jetzt schon...
Ja, das ist alles professionelle Beruhigung. Und wir haben immer gewusst, der Oilpeak wird sich erst im Nachhinein feststellen lassen. Gerade genauso wie in Amerika, der lokalen Oilpeak erst im Nachhinein festgestellt werden konnte. Das haben wir immer gewusst, das gibt es erst im Nachhinein. Und jetzt, dieses Jahr, haben sie gesagt, oh ja, Oilpeak gibt es doch. Und, apropos, das war 2006.
Spannenderweise ist der Nachweis ja gar nicht so einfach, wenn dann eine rezession dazwischen kommt. Weil bei der rezession eben die Wirtschaft runtergefahren wird und dann sinkt auch die Nachfrage. Also das konnte man in Russland ganz gut sehen.
Ja, da kommt man später noch drauf, wie halt der Zusammenhang von Ölpreisökonomie und der Verfügbarkeit von Öl ist.
Aber die Indikatoren sind schon ziemlich deutlich, also das kann man im Grunde nicht mehr leugnen.
Also was man vielleicht nochmal wiederholen sollte, weil es ein extrem wichtiges Verständnis von einem was kommt, ist, dass Peak Oil heißt nicht, dass Öl alle ist, sondern es heißt nur, dass die Menge des verfügbaren Öls, die tatsächlich gepumpt werden kann, weniger wird.
Die jährliche Fördermenge?
Die jährliche Fördermenge geht runter. Also was überhaupt geht, wenn man ganz doll an den Pumpen saugt. Und die internationale energieorganisation hat gesagt, naja, und dann haben wir dann halt noch so Felder, von denen wir wissen, dass da Öl ist, die können wir halt noch ausbeuten. Und dann gibt es noch Felder, die müssen wir noch finden. Also das ist auch ein nicht ganz so wesentlicher Teil der Kurs.
Das glaubt niemand, dass wir noch wachsende Discovery, also New Field Discovery haben in 2035, dass das noch wächst, das glauben die selber nicht, echt nicht.
Interessant an dieser Kur, finde ich halt, dass jedes Mal...
Oil Discoveries haben so einen Peak. Und die Peak ist dann glaube ich immer noch 30 Jahre vor, den exploration Peak. Und diesen Peak war schon, diesen Peak haben wir schon längst hinter uns.
Also lustigerweise gibt es noch einen anderen Effekt. Das heißt, selbst wenn es mehr Discoveries gibt, also mehr Ölfelder gefunden werden, so sinkt doch die Größe der Ölfelder, weil wir eben die Großen offensichtlich zu finden schon längst haben. Das heißt, ein weiterer Effekt ist, dass die Angaben über die Menge des Öls im Boden auch auseinandergehen, aus ökonomischen Gründen.
Also was in diesen Feldern ist, ne?
Was in den Feldern drin ist, ja.
Also es geht bis hin dazu, dass in einzelnen Ländern, die sehr abhängig sind von ihren Ölexporten, die informationen darüber, wie viel in welchen Feldern noch drin ist, werden innerhalb von diesen Ländern auch segmentiert. Also da gibt es dann halt so eine Corporate matalization, wo sie also einfach den, jeder Fieldmanager oder jede Unit, die halt einen Teilfeld managt, weiß zwar ungefähr noch, wie viel da drin ist, aber niemand in diesem Land, außer vielleicht der Präsident und zwei, drei Berater, wissen genau, wie viel insgesamt in allen Feldern noch drin ist. So und da sieht man...
Damit keine Panik ausbricht oder gibt es da noch andere?
Naja, hat natürlich mehrere Gründe. Einer der Gründe ist natürlich, dass du innerhalb der OPEC, wenn ja deine Quota nach den Reserven kalkuliert. Und zum anderen, wenn du weißt, wie viel in so einem Land noch zu holen ist, dann kannst du natürlich auch deine Politik gegenüber diesem Land entsprechend gestalten. Kannst halt dann viel sagen, naja, ihr habt sowieso nur noch zehn Jahre, dann naja, sind vielleicht eure Forderungen etwas überzogen.
Also es gibt ja so zwei, drei Lichtblicke gibt es ja noch. Also man kann zum Beispiel sehen, dass Libyen relativ große Reserven hat, die zu einem geringen Teil nur exportiert wurden. Die meisten Leute, die mit großen Ölfeldern haben so doll gesaugt, wie sie konnten. Die Ausnahmen sind eigentlich der Irak und Libyen zu einem kleineren Teil. Das heißt, es gibt im Moment auch Leute, die behaupten, ja, das ist alles kein Problem, weil im Irak noch so riesige Vorkommen sind. Aber das stimmt eben nicht, weil entsprechend die anderen Vorkommen abnehmen. Also selbst wenn man damit ein bisschen was kompensieren kann, der Trend ist doch klar.
Und die Sachen, die neu gefunden werden, sind halt auch immer schwieriger auszubeuten.
Vor allem teurer.
Die großen Vorkommen, die jetzt gerade gefunden wurden vor Brasilien, wo sie alle so gejubelt haben, da mussten sie auf sein 4.000 Meter bohren.
Ja, da gibt es auch noch mal ein wichtiger Unterschied. Es gibt teuer und es gibt Energy Return on Energy Invested nicht rendabel. Und das sind zwei andere Sachen.
Das ist in Kanada, ne? Das fand ich in Kanada bizarr. Da gibt es ja immer wieder diese Teer Sand.
Aber vielleicht sollen wir das mal kurz erklären?
Ja, in Kanada kann man das gut illustrieren. Denn die haben so Teer Sand, wo man das Öl extrahieren kann. Aber da braucht man so viel Energie für, dass deren Plan ist, dass sie dann ein paar Atomkraftwerke hinstellen, weil sie mehr Energie aufwenden müssten, als sie aus dem Öl direkt rauskriegen können wieder. Das heißt, wenn sie das gesamte Öl, was sie da fördern, gleich wieder verbrennen, um weiteres Öl zu fördern, würde sich das nicht lohnen. Es lohnt sich nur, wenn man die subventionierte Atomenergie dafür benutzt. Und das ist ja schon ein klares Zeichen, dass es sich nicht lohnt. Das ist nur so eine Notfallmaßnahme eigentlich.
Und das ist dann wieder nur erklärbar mit Panik um die Transportinfrastruktur. Die Transportinfrastruktur müsste jetzt auf andere Sachen als Öl umgeschaltet sein, ist sie aber nicht. Das dauert 20 bis 30 Jahre, bevor man so eine Infrastruktur weltweit umschaltet. Und die Zeit haben wir jetzt nicht mehr.
Arbeitet da überhaupt jemand dran, weil ich sehe da nicht so viele Indizien?
Ja, Frank hat ein E-Bike.
Ja, super.
Ich habe ein E-Bike und interessanterweise sprach ich vor einer Weile mal mit einem Hersteller, also mit jemandem, der bei einem Hersteller von so Zapfanlagen, also Tankstellen, Zapfsäulen, so arbeitet. Und die stellen sich halt schon auf eine Zeit ein, wo es nicht mehr eine Art von Energie gibt, sondern wo es halt dann solche Sachen wie zum Beispiel Energie-Cartridges gibt, die du halt mit deinem Auto mietest.
So ein Buffet sozusagen.
Die du an der Tankstelle halt austauscht und dann so einen Automaten. Oder die denken halt auch über flüssig Batterietreibstoffe nach, die dann halt so mehr so, naja, so Joghurtartige Konsistenz haben und so. Also die denken halt schon drüber nach. Aber das Problem ist halt, dass die Infrastrukturkosten, die durch diese Komplexität entstehen, sind natürlich hoch. Ist halt also schon das, was wir heute haben, irgendwie den Diesel und irgendwie die 3 Sorten Benzin und so dadurch die Gegend zu fahren und zu pumpen und zu lagern. Ist groß, aber in dem Augenblick, wo man halt noch mal mehr verschiedene Sorten hat und noch mal mehr verschiedene Konzepte hat, steigen natürlich einfach auch die ganzen Händlingkosten an. Und es funktioniert dann eben nur wiederum in den Verbreitungsgebieten. Also Diesel und Benzin krist der halt auch irgendwie im hintersten Afrika noch. So und das wird halt echt lange dauern, bis eine ähnliche Infrastruktur für ein oder mehrere Ersatzenergieträger soweit sein wird, dass ihr bis da verfügbar sein wird. Ja, wenn man das Ganze jetzt mal so ein bisschen historisch betrachten ist, Öl ja sozusagen so ein gewisser Joker, den die Menschheit hatte, um uns irgendwie aus dem Sumpf zu ziehen.
Naja, das ist halt so ein Ökosystem. Das sieht man ja auch in der Natur, wenn es plötzlich einen Standortvorteil gibt für irgendeine Rasse, sagen wir mal, weil irgendeine Tierart hier eingeschleppt wird, die hier keine natürlichen Feinde hat oder so, dann vermehrt die sich eben explosionsartig, bis die Rohstoffe alle sind. Und so ist das bei den Menschen und Öl auch gewesen. Wir haben halt einen unglaublichen exponentiellen Bevölkerungszuwachs in den letzten, weiß ich, 100 Jahren oder was, wo man dann den Punkt ziehen will. Und der ist vor allem dadurch entstanden, dass wir eben Öl haben und Lebensmittel transportieren können und Dünger haben aus Erdöl oder mit Erdölhilfe. Und vor allem eben der Transport von den Lebensmitteln, dass wir eben nicht mehr darauf angewiesen sind, überall Farmen zu haben, heißt eben, dass wir heute auch im Brachland wohnen können als Menschenrasse. Und das sieht man an der explosion der Bevölkerung sehr gut. Und das kann eigentlich nicht aufrechterhalten werden, wenn das Öl jetzt zu Ende geht. Da muss ein Wunder geschehen.
Ja, da kann man auch ein bisschen von Öl hochzoomen. Weil es gibt viele Ressourcen, die jetzt alle sind. Es gibt viele Ressourcen, wo wir jetzt so ein bisschen langsam am Ende sind. Und aus 1972 gibt es ein Report Limits to Growth, ziemlich bekannt, Club of Rome, hat das commissioned, MIT hat da Computermodelle gemacht. Und die haben gerechnet und gerechnet an, wie der Erde aus so in, wie das weitergeht, wenn jetzt die Bevölkerung weiter wächst.
Ja, also zum Beispiel sowas wie Kupfer oder schon Zement ist ein Problem. Also China hat mehr.
Die hatten ein Modell, das hieß Business as Usual. Höchst unwahrscheinlich, dass die Menschheit da nichts macht und dass wir nach 2000 noch genauso weitergemacht haben wie heute. Und dann, ja, wenn das passiert, das ist ganz unwahrscheinlich, aber wenn das passiert, dann könnte es sogar sein, dass wir schon 2010, 2020 größere Probleme haben und Kriege. Und dann ist langsam. Und da sind wir jetzt. Wir sind in Business as Usual. Wir haben nichts gemacht.
Also andere Ressourcen, die so alle werden, ist zum Beispiel auch Wasser. Also das sind nicht nur Sachen, die man aus dem Boden tankt und dann industriell verwendet, sondern auch Trinkwasser ist ein echtes Problem. Und wir haben jetzt einfach weitergemacht und jetzt ist einfach auch die Anzahl der optionen, die wir haben, deutlich kleiner geworden. Die Frage ist jetzt, was kann man überhaupt noch tun? Was kann man denn überhaupt noch tun?
Na ja, wir müssen zuerst mal einen gewissen Überblick verschaffen, was eigentlich jetzt so die Krisen sind, die uns da erwarten. Und eine der interessanten Probleme dabei ist halt natürlich zum einen, dass ja unser Lebensmittel, unsere Lebensmittelversorgung nicht nur durch Energiemangel bedroht wird, sondern auch durch bodenerosion, dadurch dass Wasser das nächste sein wird, worum Kriege geführt werden.
Na und, dass wir jetzt anfangen, so was wie biodiesel anzubauen auf den fruchtbaren Ackerböden, das ist ein echtes Problem. Das liegt ja vor allem daran, dass wir nicht angefangen haben, unsere Transportinfrastruktur umzustellen und dass wir jetzt immer noch Benzin brauchen für unsere Autos. Und der Notnagel ist eben dieses biodieselzeug, was ja eigentlich ganz gut klingt, aber in der Praxis ist das eben keine Lösung, weil dadurch weniger Lebensmittel angebaut werden können auf den Ackerflächen. Und es kommt zusätzlich noch das Problem dazu, dass es auch spekulationen gibt, dadurch, dass sich abzeichnet, dass die Lebensmittel knapp werden, ist das ein spekulationsobjekt geworden, wo man am Devisenmarkt irgendwelche Geschäfte macht inzwischen. Also es gab gerade den Bericht, dass Hedgefonds großflächig Ackerbauflächen in Afrika gekauft haben, wo dann die Leute daneben verhungern und von hilfsorganisationen mit Lebensmittelspenden am Leben gehalten werden. Und rechts baut der Hedgefonds für den Export rein, für den Export Lebensmittel an.
Oder Energie betreuen.
Oder natürlich, es ist ja noch schlimmer, oder Energie. Und hungrigen Leuten kann man auch nicht böse sein, wenn sie sagen, wir haben hier die Ackerfläche an biodiesel verloren, dann machen wir halt den Urwald daneben weg, weil wir hier auch noch Lebensmittel brauchen. Also es ist nicht so einfach, den Leuten da böse zu sein, wenn sie sich hier um den Urwald scheren. Aber da hat halt natürlich die ganze Menschheit ein Problem mit.
Naja, das hat der nächste Einfluss eben, dass der Klimawandel dann halt einfach nur noch schlimmer wird, wenn wir die Wälder verlieren. Und wir sind auch beim Klimawandel in den projektionen, wo niemand so richtig gedacht hat, dass es so schlimm werden wird. Wie war es mit dem Seeeis?
Da gibt es so Grafiken, dass im Arctic von Winter auf Sommer gibt es eine Menge an millions of Square Kilometers, was mit Eis bedeckt ist. Und das geht dramatisch runter. Nach 2005 sagen Scientists, it fell off a cliff.
Also es geht noch schlimmer runter, als die projektionen waren. Das geht eh schon runter, wegen Jahreszeiten. Aber es geht eben noch schlimmer runter, als die übelsten projektionen, die wir haben.
Das selbe haben wir auch beim Anstieg des Meeresspiegels, was gerade für euch Holländer natürlich besonders interessant ist. Da sind wir auch außerhalb der mittlerweile der projektionen, die halt noch in von diesem Weltklimarat beschlossen wurden.
In 2007 gab es Modelle und da gab es so eine Bandbreite. Und die best cases in der heutigen Studien liegen schon weit über die worst cases von 2007. Und das ist schon signifikant, weil das heißt in vier Jahre hat sich das also schon verdoppelt, was die denken, dass da passieren wird. Aber das das Grundproblem ist halt wie auf Englisch gesagt wird, the economy is a wholly owned subsidiary of the ecology. Alles, was wir Menschen machen, nimmt aus der Natur Rohstoffe und bringt Abfälle in die Natur wieder zurück rein. Und die Erde hat eine bestimmte Kapazität an Sources für Rohstoffe und eine bestimmte Kapazität an Zinks für Abfälle. Exponential growth is a bitch. Wenn die menschliche Aktivität wächst, wächst auch die Kapazität, um weiter zu wachsen. So sieht Wachstum halt aus. Das heißt, auch bei dreieinhalb Prozent pro Jahr, was ein moderater Wachstum für menschliche Aktivität genannt wird, verdoppelt sich die menschliche Aktivität und damit auch die Belastung der Sources und Zinks in der Ökologie jede 20 Jahre. Und in China wird noch viel schneller gewachsen. Und verdoppeln ist so eine Exponential-Kurve. Wenn man das jede 20 Jahre macht, dann ist man irgendwann übersteigt, was der ganze Planeten an Sources und Zinks zu bieten hat. Wir drehen jetzt, sagen wir mal, bei 140, 150 Prozent der Planeten. Was heißt, dass wir nicht, dass wir...
Also du meinst, wir haben 140, 150 Prozent der Carrying Capacity erreicht?
Wir sind auf 140 Prozent der Carrying Capacity. Was heißt, wir leben nicht mehr auf der Zins an unserer Spargelder, sondern wir leben von dieser Spargelder selber. Und die Lebensqualität ändert sich damit nicht. Wenn man Spargelder hat und irgendwann gibt man mehr aus, als dass man Zinsen von der Bank bekommt, dann ändert sich die Lebensqualität nicht. Nur irgendwann ist das Geld alle. Und dann ändert sich die Lebensqualität doch dramatisch. Und da sind wir. Wir haben diese Carrying Capacity of Earth überschritten. Und alle Modelle, die es dafür gibt, auch schon aus 1972, reden von population Overshoot und population Collapse. Das war dann in diese Modelle so 2040 bis 2060 errechnet. Aber da gibt es dann so einen rapiden Bevölkerungsanwachs und dann irgendwann crasht das wieder runter. Und es wäre ganz schön, wenn das irgendwie vorzubeugen wäre. Dafür gibt es dann auch so einen Begriff, das heißt dann die Soft Landing scenarios. Wie kriegen wir das irgendwie so geregelt, dass die Menschheit sich auf einem Level stabilisiert und auch die Aktivitäten sich auf einem Level stabilisieren, wo wir weiter können, wo wir weitermachen können? Steady State Economies ist so ein Wort. Non-Growth Economies.
Also zwei Sachen würde ich da gerne anmerken. Erstens, diese Modelle sind nicht irgendwie aus der Luft gegriffen und könnten sich als falsch herausstellen, sondern das kann man in der biologie beobachten. Zum Beispiel gab es so eine Insel irgendwo in der Arktis, wo irgendwelche Elche hingegangen sind und die haben halt keine natürlichen Feinde und viel Fressen gehabt und haben sich halt exponentiell vermehrt. Und die Forscher sind alle 10 Jahre mal zu dieser Insel gegangen und sind halt das erste Mal hingegangen, haben so zwei, drei Elche gesehen und dachten, oh, ist ja komisch, was machen die denn hier? Und nach 10 Jahren war die gesamte Insel überrannt mit Elchen. Da haben sie gesagt, naja, das ist ja schon eigentlich mehr als die Insel abkann und nach 10 Jahren war alle tot. Also das ist nicht theoretisch, sondern das kann man immer wieder beobachten, auch bei Menschen übrigens. Also wenn es irgendwie so eine Insel gibt.
Gründern.
Trotzdem versuchen zu modellen, wie ist die Welt in 50 oder 100 Jahren? Da gibt es schon sehr viele Parameter, die man irgendwie in diese Software verarbeiten muss. Die Margen für Unsicherheit da sind groß. Aber die generelle Bewegung ist klar. Aber die Basisprinzipien, dass das irgendwie schiefgeht, dass wir die generation sind, die es nicht noch mal verdoppeln sehen kann, dass wir mit dreieinhalb Prozent pro Jahr Wachstum nicht noch mal die menschliche Aktivität verdoppeln sehen können, das ist klar. Das ist mathematische Sicherheit, da kann man sich nicht dran entziehen.
So, der zweite Punkt ist, dass es auch ein mentales Problem ist. Also wenn man jetzt in die Bildzeitung guckt, da war irgendwie vor ein paar Tagen so, oder BZ, irgendwie Berliner, so eine Boulevard-Scheiß, da war halt irgendwie so eine Überschrift, gute Nachricht, Baby-Boom in Ostberlin. Weil die halt vorher Panik gemacht hatten, unsere Bevölkerung stirbt weg und dann heißt es, oh super, wir haben Baby-Boom. Und diese Idee, Bevölkerungszuwachs gut, Bevölkerung senken schlecht, da müssen wir weg von.
Wachstum ist alles, was der Menschheit bis jetzt gemacht hat.
Ja, da sind wir halt gewöhnt dran.
Aber das ist alles, was wir damit assoziieren ist gut und alles, was mit mit mit Decline zu tun hat, ist schlecht. Das ist halt unsere Geschichte. Das haben wir 50.000 Jahre, haben Menschen nichts anderes gemacht, als versuchen, ihren Aktivitäten wachsen zu lassen.
Und inklusive unseres Geldes.
Ja.
Also es ist halt einer der wesentlichen Problempunkte an diesem Ende des Wachstums, was wir jetzt ja gerade sehen ist, dass unser Geld auf Wachstum beruht. Das haben wir in der letzten Sendung, in der vorletzten auch ein bisschen besprochen, einfach mal zu verstehen, dass unser Geld immer nur von morgen geborgt ist. Also von dem Geld, was morgen erzeugt wird durch Wachstum. Und es funktioniert halt so lange ganz gut, wie es Wirtschaftswachstum gibt, also wie halt morgen mehr ist als heute. Und in dem Umblick, wo morgen weniger ist als heute, bricht es halt eben auch unser Geldsystem zusammen. Ich glaube, das ist das, was wir gerade sehen, wenn wir so die Nachrichten klicken. Wir sehen, wir haben da sozusagen eine, ja wir leben in interessanten Zeiten, wie dieser angeblich chinesische Fluch es sagte, von dem wir herausgefunden haben, dass offensichtlich kein chinesischer Fluch ist.
Ist doch egal, was es ist. Aber jedenfalls der Punkt ist, wir haben ein Problem, wir müssen das einsehen und wir müssen uns fragen, wie reagieren wir darauf? Was können wir jetzt tun?
Ich habe hier aufs Camp mit vielen Leuten gesprochen und die erste reaktion von vielen Leuten war dann, ist doch schade, weil man will doch als Mensch weiter wachsen, man will eigentlich weiter nach dem Westen ziehen, können wir nicht im Weltraum rein, wir müssen doch dieses, wenn hier zu voll ist, müssen wir irgendwo anders hin und da weiter wachsen. Das ist auch so ein Ding, was in die Menschen drin ist. Und das ist dann erstmal schade, bis man die Leute dann erzählt, dass diese Welt, die jetzt auf uns zukommt, wobei wir neue Modelle erfinden müssen, wobei es ein Patchwork an funktionierende und nicht funktionierende Modelle gibt, wobei es vielleicht City-States gibt und diese Zeiten von Zerfall und das Suchen nach neuen Modellen, die funktionieren, dieses Non-Growth Economy, das Erfinden von das Ganze Neue, dass das eigentlich auch pioneering ist.
Vor allem ist es spannend, weil wir es noch nicht hatten. Und das ist doch das Tollste, was man haben kann im Leben. Sachen machen, die es noch nicht gab.
Genau. Und da wollen wir mal jetzt ein bisschen drüber reden. Nachdem wir sozusagen jetzt durch den... Wir hatten in unserem Vortrag, hatten wir irgendwie einen emotional Low Point Indicator Slide. Und der Zeitpunkt ist ungefähr jetzt in dieser Sendung. Also dass wir jetzt mal versuchen, ein bisschen drüber zu reden. Was passiert denn eigentlich? Also ganz praktisch im Alltag. Und wie geht man damit um? Und was für Möglichkeiten hat man da, möglicherweise eben auch neue Ideen zu entwickeln, ja auch zu überleben, was ja auch nicht so ganz unwichtig ist. Und Zukunft halt auch zu gestalten. Und möglicherweise sogar vielleicht sogar ein bisschen Spaß dabei zu haben.
Na in erster Linie erstmal sehen, welche Probleme sich da ergeben könnten. Damit wir da nicht überrascht werden.
Ja, also gut, vielleicht war es noch nicht der emotion Lowpoint.
Naja, ich meine, man muss es ja kommen sehen, damit man was tun kann dagegen.
Ja, also um es zusammenzufassen, unser Leben wird vermutlich doch sich in den nächsten Jahren ziemlich drastisch ändern. Es wird vermutlich nicht das Ende der Welt sein. Zumindest sieht es gerade nicht danach aus, sondern es wird mehr so ein, ja Dinge werden halt ein bisschen holpriger und ein bisschen interessanter und schwieriger, aber es wird sicherlich nicht der Zeitpunkt.
Was erstmal wichtig ist, um zu sagen, ist, dass wir jetzt nicht, grosso modo sind wir jetzt nicht glücklich. Leute, die ich kenne, arbeiten sich im Kreis, um irgendwie ihr Haus bezahlt zu bekommen. Wir werden in großen Mengen mediziert. Antidepressiva, Antipsychotika, Kinder bekommen Ritalin. Alles, um uns funktionieren zu lassen, in einer immer schneller, nach unten wachsenden Wirtschaft. Wir sind jetzt nicht glücklich. Bevor alles schwierig wird und vielleicht werden wir da ganz unglücklich. Ich sehe eigentlich diese ganzen Änderungen, die auf uns zukommen als für individuelle Menschen grundsätzlich positiv. Auch wenn es schwierig wird, auch wenn diese Menschen schwierige Zeiten durchqueren müssen. Ich glaube, ich werde das grundsätzlich für die meisten Menschen positiv aus.
Und zwar unter anderem deswegen, weil der Stabilität muss ja nicht zwingend heißen, dass es eben ein stabiles Wachstum ist. Stabilität kann ja eben auch heißen, dass es einfach erstmal alles etwas weniger schnell, etwas weniger hektisch, etwas weniger konkurrenzbelastet wird. Und einer der Effekte, den wir sicherlich haben werden, ist, gerade wenn Öl teurer wird, ist das alles langsamer wird. Also der einfachste Weg, größere Mengen Öl zu sparen in der Transportunterstruktur, ist, die Dinge langsamer ablaufen zu lassen. Also Schiffe langsamer fahren zu lassen, Flugzeuge langsamer fliegen zu lassen, Autos langsamer fahren zu lassen, spart unglaubliche Mengen an Treibstoff.
Wobei so richtig schnell fahren die bisher auch nicht. Die haben halt dann entsprechend mehr Schiffe unterwegs. Du optimierst nicht, wie viel du transportierst, sondern du optimierst, wie viel pro Zeiteinheit im Hafen von Rotterdam ankommt. Und wenn du langsamer fährst, musst du halt mehr Schiffe unterwegs haben. Aber das ist ja ein Festkostendings, das sind ja keine laufenden Kosten. Also du kannst bei den gleichen laufenden Kosten, kannst du entweder ein paar schnelle Schiffe oder mehrere langsamere Schiffe haben, die bringen gleich viel Material pro Woche an.
Stimmt nicht. Als die erste Finanzkrise, die Schuldenkrise in 2008 ausbrach, sind die ganzen Ozean-Containerschiffe langsamer gefahren. Dieselbe Schiffe sind einfach langsamer gefahren, damit es richtig viel Treibstoff gespart hat.
Also ich habe gelesen, dass es eher damit zu tun hatte, dass sie glauben, dass in der Zeit, wo sie fahren, die Preise nur hochgehen können, weil sie gerade im Keller waren. Das war was ich gehört habe. Ich habe gehört, dass die Leute Containerschiffe weise Öl gekauft haben und das dann ein Jahr das Schiff einfach mal da rumliegen lassen.
Das ist aber ein anderes Problem. Worum es geht, ist ja tatsächlich ein langsamer werdender Wirtschaft. Das sehen wir heutzutage auch schon bei Fluggesellschaften. Wenn du so Billigfluggesellschaften fliegst, die fliegen halt mit 700 kmh, nicht mit 900 kmh. Also es ist halt zwei Stunden länger für einen Langstreckenflug, aber du sparst halt eben noch ein paar hundert Euro, weil du halt eben nicht so viel Treibstoff verbrauchst.
Aber das ist ja nicht wirklich langsamer. Also für mich ist es langsamer als Passagier, aber für die Fluglinie, die transportiert genau gleich wie die Leute pro Tag.
Genau, also es gibt da halt auf jeden Fall noch eine Menge Reserven im System, ist die interessante Nachfrage. Wenn wir alle damit leben, dass es alles ein bisschen länger dauert, dass der Container aus China tatsächlich sechs Wochen dauert, statt vier Wochen bis er hier ist, oder sechs statt zwei Wochen, dann ist da nochmal eine Menge Reserve im System, die einfach nur durch eine Akzeptanz von geringerer Geschwindigkeit da ist. Das heißt, wir können halt eine Menge Öl und auch eine Menge Stress sparen, indem wir halt einfach sagen, okay, das ist langsamer. Langsamer heißt natürlich auch weniger Wachstum in der gleichen Zeiteinheit. Also du kannst halt nicht genauso viel oder mehr bewegen in der selben Zeiteinheit, sondern es wird halt weniger. Und eine andere Möglichkeit ist natürlich Energieeffizienz zu steigern. Und da zeigt sich aber das interessante Problem, dass bei allem, was wir bisher getan haben, um Energieeffizienz zu steigern.
Das haben wir zwar geschafft, aber der Effekt war gegenteilig, ne?
Genau, der Effekt war bestenfalls Null. Weil die Leute, wenn sie anfangen zu sehen, okay, die neue aircondition verbraucht weniger Strom, lassen sie halt länger laufen. Oder kaufen sie überhaupt erst mal eine. Ja, also das ist durchaus ein Phänomen, dass man halt dann so einen kompensationseffekt hat, der die Effizienzgewinne wieder auffrisst. Heißt also dieses, wir werden uns da schon irgendwie rauswieseln, stimmt halt einfach nur zu einem geringen Prozentsatz. Es wird uns möglicherweise Zeit kaufen, die wir brauchen, aber es wird nicht dazu führen, dass sich das Problem löst. So sondern wir fahren halt langsamer, wir machen Energieeffizienz, aber es öve trotzdem immer noch weniger. Das heißt, es ist halt der...
Ja, also der Punkt, den ich zu machen versucht habe, war, dass es nicht heißt, dass wir hier weniger iPods im Regal haben, sondern es dauert nur länger, bis das iPod hier ist. Aber das ist uns für uns egal, weil dann schicken die halt mehr Schiffe, die langsamer fahren.
Ich glaube, wir werden ein wenig iPods im Regal haben.
Magst du?
Ja. Also ich gehe ganz fest davon aus, dass also die... Gut wäre nicht das Schlechteste, wenn du nicht fängst... .dass die Update-Frequenz gerade von Konsumgütern...
Ja, die Update-Frequenz, die wird natürlich sinken, aber das heißt nicht, dass wir hier weniger Waren haben, sondern das heißt nur, dass die länger unterwegs waren, bis sie bei uns im Regal standen.
Ja, und es wird auch nicht dazu führen, dass es jedes Jahr ein neues iPhone gibt, sondern vielleicht nur alle zwei Jahre, drei Jahre, vier Jahre, fünf Jahre. Das wäre auch nicht das Schlechteste, oder? Wir sind ja ohnehin an vielen Punkten, also gerade zum Beispiel bei Rechenpower, sind wir an einem Punkt, wo es ohnehin gerade so gewisse, natürliche Grenzen von z.B. Moore's Law sich zu offenbaren scheinen. Es gibt ja diese ganzen angeblichen Gesetze, zu Moore's Law ist auch so ein Beispiel, sind ja auch alle so eine exponentiellen Wachstumsdinger. Also jedes Jahr wird es immer mehr, mehr Pixel, mehr Prozessorleistung, mehr Speicher. Und so richtig viel braucht man davon mittlerweile aber eigentlich auch nicht mehr.
Naja, wir werden vielleicht eher auf Software-Updates umsteigen als auf Hardware-Updates. Dass einfach Features dann freigeschaltet werden und das ist ein iPhone 5 oder was weiß ich was.
Naja, oder die Software.
Naja, eben, aber das...
Vielleicht könnte sogar die Software mal besser werden. Also Pultein.
Also gut, da würde ich jetzt nicht von ausgehen.
Die Wahrscheinlichkeit ist nicht so hoch.
Ja, also jedenfalls, das heißt nicht, dass wir alle hungern werden, wenn es ölteurer wird, sondern das heißt nur, dass wir dann vielleicht keine Avocado mehr hier haben oder keine, was weiß ich, Bananen, sondern dass wir eben mehr lokale Sachen hier haben werden. Und das ist ja ein Trend, den wir sowieso beobachten aus anderen Gründen. Allerdings in letzter Zeit bei Essen zumindest, dass diese bio-bewegung dazu geführt hat, dass wir mehr lokale Sachen haben. Und die Milch kommt inzwischen auch nicht mehr aus der Deutschland-Zentrale, sondern die kommt schon dann aus Brandenburg oder so, wenn man in Berlin kauft. Also den Trend sieht man ja eh. Vielleicht, ob das jetzt mit dem Öl zu tun hat oder nicht, sei mal dahingestellt, aber das wird auf jeden Fall mehr werden.
Ja, und viele Sachen werden eben auch einfach schlicht nicht verfügbar sein.
Tropenhölzer sind dann endlich durch.
Fertig aufbereiteten Obstsalat in der Plastikschale im Supermarkt. Wo die Früchte nach Marokko geflogen werden, da werden sie dann geschnitten und verpackt in diese Dinge, in Tiefencontainer geladen und wieder nach Deutschland geflogen, um dann da irgendwie in den Supermarkt gebracht zu werden. So was wird dann wohl enden. Oder zumindest nur noch irgendwie so teuer sein, dass es sich nicht mehr lohnt, das irgendwie im großen Maßstab zu betreiben. Es gibt natürlich Leute, die sagen, ja Pff, also Herrgott, uns wird da schon was einfallen. Der Menschheit wird irgendwas einfallen. Es wird da halt irgendwie einen Durchbruch geben, die kalte kernfusion. Ja, kalte kernfusion zum Beispiel.
Singularity.
Ja, oder Singularity. Ich meine, bei kalter kernfusion habe ich immer noch so eine gewisse kleine Hoffnung.
Dauert nur noch 20 Jahre, ich bin mir sicher.
Naja, ich denke, es wird schneller gehen, falls es überhaupt geht. Aber das Interessante daran ist, es würde nicht alle Probleme lösen. Sondern es würde bestenfalls ein Drittel des Problems lösen, nämlich halt irgendwie die Verfügbarkeit von Energie. Und damit lassen sich zwar viele andere Probleme lösen, aber zum Beispiel ist halt irgendwie sowas wie Anstieg des Meeresspiegels und Klimawandel. Die Probleme werden wir ohnehin haben und die gehen halt auch nicht so ohne weiteres weg. Im Gegenteil, wenn wir jetzt plötzlich wieder eine Energiequere hätten, die irgendwie nahezu kostenlos und universiell verfügbar ist, würden wir mit diesem Wachstumsding so weitermachen. Und dann würden uns keine Ahnung, Peak Copper treffen oder keine Ahnung, was als nächstes alle geht.
Ja, also wir müssen jedenfalls dezentralisieren. Das ist völlig klar und man sieht das ja jetzt schon bei der Energieversorgung. Das ist ja ein schöner Trend. In Deutschland sieht man immer mehr Windräder und so. Das wird zunehmen, weil die Transportkosten eben auch bei Gütern zunehmen. Und wir werden wahrscheinlich weniger sinnlosen Transport von Gütern sehen, was ja im Moment auch hier so eine subventionsgeschichte ist. Dass du irgendwie in der EU subventionen abgreifen kannst, wenn es ein internationales Whatever ist und deswegen halt Marokko. Oder bei Textilien habe ich mal gelesen, dass sie das dann in Spanien die Teile einkarren und das dann aber immer nach Bulgarien fahren und da nähen lassen, weil das dann zwei EU, was weiß ich. Also das lohnt sich alles nur genau jetzt, wo das Öl billig ist.
Dann hast du einen Prozess, was eigentlich Deglobalisierung ist.
Ja, aber das ist ja auch nicht schlecht, oder?
Nee, nee, das ist nicht schlecht. Ich sag nur, die ganze heutige Ideologie im Markt und wie Regierungen jetzt ihren Policies machen, ist Globalisierung. Alle Märkte müssen offen sein und alle Preise müssen irgendwie offen zustande kommen und jeder muss auf jeder Markt agieren können und alle müssen alles kaufen und verkaufen können.
Das wird auch so bleiben oder nicht, aber du wirst halt plötzlich Transportkosten haben, die das kaputt machen.
Davon kannst du nicht ausgehen. Also ist ganz klar, dass eine sinnvolle option für Regierungen, die sehen, dass es einen Deglobalisierungstrend gibt und sich einen Vorteil verschaffen wollen, ist protektionismus.
Naja, aber da gehen wir doch im Grunde seit Jahren davon aus, dass es irgendwann wieder fett losgeht.
Ja eben, deswegen kannst du nicht...
Das ist nicht bisher, aber nicht geschehen. Doch, doch, wo denn?
Das ist in diversen Ländern, gerade in Südamerika zum Beispiel.
Ja gut, aber doch die EU oder die, die uns betreffen.
Die EU macht fetten protektionismus gegen den Rest der Welt.
Ja, nach außen, aber nicht.
Ja, na gut, ich meine, wir sind halt irgendwie... Die EU kannst du in dem Fall...
Ja, aber wo kommen denn die meisten Sachen, die du kaufst? Die sind, also irgendwie Taiwan, China bei Elektronik natürlich, aber ansonsten so Lebensmittel.
Eben, also der protektionismus ist a life and kicking da.
Ja, aber ich will sagen, das kann immer noch aus Spanien kommen, unser Obst.
Ja, ich meine, das ist eine Frage von der Größe der ökonomischen Einheit und die logische, große ökonomische Einheit ist momentan die EU-Große und die wird halt kleiner werden.
Das ist natürlich eine interessante Frage, ob wir jetzt über diese Banken und Schuldenkrise, wenn wir da die Hazardöre im Süden abstoßen, wo dann unser Obst herkommt.
Das wird weiterhin daher kommen.
Naja, aber es ist ja dann das.
Die Immobilien sind da jetzt gerade ganz billig.
Dann werden die doch betroffen von dem protektionismus.
Die Immobilien, die da gerade sind, sind gerade ganz billig.
Naja, die Immobilien helfen ja nicht, wenn das Wasser alle ist und das ist ja ein Problem in Spanien. Naja, also was wird denn konkret sich für uns ändern, abgesehen davon, dass sich das Warenangebot vielleicht verschiebt im Supermarkt?
Na, ich gehe davon aus, dass der...
Wir werden weniger Jobs haben, bei denen man rumfährt oder...
Na, zumindest wenn wir weniger Jobs haben, bei denen man...
Nach New York jettet.
Nach New York jettet und rumfahren muss, so. Und es wird vermutlich auch dazu kommen, dass die Leute echt verunsichert werden. Also das ist halt einfach der...
Aber das ist doch jetzt schon so, oder?
Naja, überleg mal. Wir haben momentan noch so was Ähnliches wie ein gewisses Stabilitätsgefühl. Natürlich gibt es halt so böse Randalierer und irgendwie die Leute verlieren ihre Arbeitsplätze, aber wenn es nicht mehr aufhört, wenn sozusagen das, was wir jetzt haben, diese Nachrichtenlage, dieses... Wir haben halt bei unserem Vortrag gesagt, wir haben ja erwartet, dass unser Vortrag aktuell ist, aber nicht, dass es sozusagen die laufende Sportberichterstattung ist, zu dem, was wir gerade erleben, aber das hört jetzt einfach nicht mehr auf. Und irgendwie, wenn Unruhen in London...
Das Versprechen ist Recovery. Davon reden alle. When economic recovery happens, an economic recovery, this recovery...
Aber das darf doch gar nicht passieren, da hängt doch zu viel davon.
Recovery heißt, wir kriegen wieder so eine periode von zwei Jahrzehnten, wo es wieder Wachstum gibt, wo die Kurve wieder langsam...
Wo die 90s wiederkommen.
Und das ist ein Idee, das wird es nicht geben.
Ja.
Das ist... Dann müsste sich die Menschheit noch mal verdoppeln. Das geht nicht.
Wie kann ich mich denn vorbereiten? Wie oft muss ich mich dann einstellen an Problemen, die jetzt vielleicht nicht offensichtlich sind?
Eines der Probleme ist, dass wenn die Leute verunsichert werden, dann werden sie wieder verstärkt organisierten religionen zuwenden.
Das kann man ja schon beobachten in den letzten Jahren.
Und auch was wir da gerade sehen, zum Beispiel mit der Tea Party in den USA.
Das ist ja auch so was.
Das ist auch genau so was. Also halt so eine Zuwendung zu irrationalen Glaubenssystemen, die halt dann auch teilweise sehr extrem werden können. Also ich meine, wenn man es so anguckt, so in einigen Gebieten, gerade auch in den USA, was da an Wissenschaftsfeindlichkeit passiert und an negativer Einstellung gegenüber rationalem Denken. Also Fakten sind ja eher dann noch eine sehr virtuelle Angelegenheit. Das wird definitiv mehr werden. Und ich kann mir durchaus vorstellen, dass es eben bis hin dazu geht, dass es eine richtige Wissenschaftsfeindlichkeit als Ideologie gibt, nach dem Motto, ihr habt uns in diese Scheiße reingeritten mit eurem technischen Fortschritt. Und wir wollen uns wieder zurück zu irgendwie, keine Ahnung, Flügen mit Oxen oder so oder Flügen mit SUVs. Keine Ahnung, wie es dann heutzutage sein wird. Und ein anderer Effekt, den wir jetzt ja gerade schon in Großbritannien live unter Farbe beobachten können, ist, dass der Abstieg in so Polizeistaatsideologien kann echt rapide werden. Also ich weiß nicht, ob ihr gehört habt, was da heute in den UK passiert. Die schmeißen Leute aus den Wohnungen, weil ihre Kinder da sich an den riots beteiligt haben, weil sie irgendwie in den Mietverträgen für die Sozialwohnung Klauseln drin haben, dass die Insassen sich nicht an irgendwelchen kriminellen Handlungen beteiligen dürfen.
Boah, übel. Wobei, das ist ja auch so konspirologisch interessant, weil es gibt ja mehrere so Geschichten. Aus Amerika zum Beispiel gab es über die letzten Jahre hinweg immer wieder so Geschichten, dass die irgendwelche Lager bauen, wo es dann hieß, das sei für Katastrophen. Und wo man sich schon fragt, was für eine Katastrophe, wovon reden die da eigentlich? Und als dann wirklich eine Katastrophe kam, wir hier Kathrina, waren sie überhaupt nicht vorbereitet, also da gab es schon mehrere Sachen, die eigentlich keinen Sinn ergeben, und die aber plötzlich doch so ein bisschen Sinn ergeben, wenn man das unter dem Blickwinkel betrachtet. Na ja, vielleicht gehen die davon aus, dass hier demnächst die Unruhen losgehen, weil sich die Leute hier kein Essen mehr leisten können. Also das finde ich überhaupt eine wichtige Sache. Wenn das Öl teurer wird, dann heißt es ja nicht nur, dass man halt an weniger Tagen heizt. Sondern das ist eine riesige Kaskade an Folgesachen, die auch teurer werden. Ja, Flüge wird dann gar nicht mehr gehen, außer man ist superreich. So wenig Flüge kann man schon mal direkt vergessen. Das wird es einfach überhaupt nicht mehr geben.
Du hast gerade gefragt, was kann ich denn machen, mich vorzubereiten?
Genau. Ich habe mir halt gedacht, als ich über das Thema nachgedacht habe, wenn ich jetzt reich wäre, irgendwie so ein millionär, sagen wir mal, dann würde ich mir angesichts dieser Überlegungen denken, wo ich brauche aber noch mehr Geld. Die million ist zwar angemessen, wenn man irgendwie von einem weiter wachsenden System ausgeht, wo ich halt investieren kann oder so und kriege dann meine Zinsen und so, wo das alles schön stabil ist, aber wenn ich davon ausgehe, dass ich demnächst hier der Pöbel eine Aufruhe macht, dann brauche ich jetzt mehr Sicherheit. Und das war für mich so ein Aha-Moment. Da habe ich mir überlegt, na ja, vielleicht erklärt sich so, dass die Reichten angefangen haben, jetzt super reich werden zu wollen, dass diese diese Schere weiter auseinanderklafft, obwohl die ja sich im Moment überhaupt nicht mehr kaufen können von dem Geld. Ja, nur wenn ich jetzt eine Milliarde statt einer million habe, dann kaufe ich mir vielleicht eine größere Wohnung, irgendwie eine Yacht oder so. Aber das ist ja nicht...
Na ja, was solche Leute schon tun, ist, dass sie sich mehr Abstand kaufen. Ja, eben. Also sie kaufen sich halt einfach so viel Land, dass irgendwie, falls irgendjemand mal was von ihnen will, sie die halt irgendwie 100 Kilometer weit kommen sehen.
Das ist aber ein Schutzmechanismus, was ich... also das ist genau der Punkt, den ich machen will, dass die plötzlich ein erhöhtes Schutzbedürfnis sehen, weil sie davon ausgehen, dass hier demnächst die zivilisation wegbricht. Und wenn man im Moment zu den Privilegierten gehört, dann denkt man sich, naja, dann will ich vielleicht selbst für meine Sicherheit sorgen müssen. Und dann gibt es die Armen in Amerika, radikalisieren sich dann in irgendwelchen Militias und kaufen sich da Knarren und machen sich einen Trainingscamp im Wald. Aber die Reichen denken halt nach, naja, dann brauch ich vielleicht ein großes Gelände oder eine Insel. Inseln sind wohl gerade sehr populär, obwohl da der Wasserstand wahrscheinlich ein Problem wird. Aber ich will sagen, es ist nicht so, dass wir jetzt die Ersten sind, die darüber nachdenken, was man da konkret tun kann. Sondern das sieht für mich so ganz klar so aus, als wenn die Privilegierten das schon länger kommen sehen und sich halt überlegen, wie sie sich da jetzt vorbereiten sollen. Und ja, das ist schon passiert sozusagen.
Also passieren tut es eigentlich so spätestens seit der letzten Finanzkrise 2007-2008, wo es dann bis hingeht zu Büchern von irgendwelchen ehemaligen Großbankern, die dann hinten drin noch irgendwie so drei Seiten drin haben, nach dem allgemeinen Gefahr so. Und ansonsten hab ich mir gerade noch eine Hütte im Wald gekauft mit genug Waffen und Konserven für ein paar Jahre.
Lustigerweise gab es eine sehr interessante Sache vor zwei, drei Jahren. Da gab es einen Trend, dass sich die Banker neben der Wohnung in Manhattan, also im Reichenviertel, noch eine Wohnung im Armenviertel gekauft haben oder so irgendwie lower middle class. Weil sie dachten, na vielleicht geht im Reichenviertel demnächst die Randale los und dann tauche ich da irgendwo und anonym in meiner Zweitwohnung unter. Also es geht nicht nur ich ziehe jetzt in Wald, sondern aber durchaus derselbe Hintergrund. Die Idee, die kommen demnächst und wollen mich hier, der Mob kommt und will mich mit den Spitzgabeln aus der Stadt treiben. Also diese Bedrohung kann man glaube ich schon ganz gut sehen bei manchen Leuten. Diese, jedenfalls die Gefahr, dass sie die fürchten und dass sie versuchen, sich da zu schützen.
Der Abstand zwischen Arm und Reich war auch nie mehr so groß seit Krise der 20er, 30er Jahre.
Und da gibt es eigentlich keine Begründung für, oder? Also es gibt keinen echten, ich habe keinen Vorteil, wenn ich jetzt statt einer Milliarde 10 Milliarden habe. Oder habe ich da einen Vorteil?
Ja, da gibt es verschiedene Begründungen.
Begründungen braucht man nicht, es gab Gelegenheit. Es ist Gelegenheit entstanden, dadurch, dass Policy zu kaufen war. Sobald Policy zu kaufen ist, kaufen sich die Reichen die Möglichkeit, reicher zu werden.
Du meinst, die machen das automatisch, auch wenn sie sich nicht bedroht fühlen? Ja. Na gut.
Also es hat einfach damit zu tun, dass der, also dein Gefühl von Reichtum hat ja immer mit deiner Peergroup zu tun. Also du fühlst dich halt wohlhabend und reich oder eben entsprechend reich, je nachdem, wenn du ein bisschen reicher bist als deine Peers.
Dein Nachbar.
Und bei denen ist es halt eben auch so, dass die, naja, deren Peergroup wird halt auch immer reicher, also müssen sie halt mit. Na jedenfalls können wir zusammenfassen, dass der...
Aber du hast immer noch diese Frage gestellt, was kann ich dann tun, mich da vorzubereiten, was kann ich dagegen tun?
Na dagegen, kann man überhaupt was tun?
Dagegen kann man nicht viel tun, aber was kann ich tun, um für mich irgendwie die Effekte irgendwie im Griff zu halten?
Sollte ich jetzt Landbau lernen?
Schadet nie, aber ich glaube nicht, dass wir bald, also innerhalb 10, 20 Jahre, in eine situation landen, wo alle Landwirtschaft machen müssen. Landwirtschaft hat mal echt viele Hände gebraucht. Es wird wieder mehr Hände brauchen, als es jetzt braucht. Aber bis es wieder so viel braucht, als vor 200 Jahren, ist noch eine Weile weg. Ich glaube, wichtig ist, dass man in ein Netz von anderen Menschen ist, die alle auch was können. Und dass du auch weißt, wer was machen kann und wer nur quatscht. Und in ein funktionales Vertrauensnetz zu sein und mit anderen Leute Projekte aufsetzen zu können und sich irgendwie definieren können, was will ich denn machen? Mit welcher Gruppe von Leuten können wir uns zusammen irgendwie organisieren? Und vielleicht werden das immer kleinere Gruppen werden. Vielleicht kann man sich die kommende 20 Jahre noch in Städte handhaben. Muss man danach doch irgendwie, gibt es eine periode, dass man doch aus der Stadt raus muss? Kann man nicht sagen. Kann auch sein, dass das nicht so ist.
Redest du jetzt von Gruppen 10 Leute oder so in Kleinstadt?
Nee, ich glaube, dass es noch lange, lange Zeit, mein Leben lang, Möglichkeiten gibt zu überleben für Gruppen von 10.000, 20.000 Leuten. Dass sich größere, kleinere Städte, größere Dörfer organisieren können und sich irgendwie Nahrungsmittel, Wasser, Sicherheit und auch diese, dass die Verschiedenheit an, an Fähigkeiten, die man braucht, um, um irgendwie ein, ein zivilisiertes Leben im, im Stande zu halten, dass es das geben wird.
Also ich denke, dass, dass dieser Punkt-
An manche Stellen, an manche Stellen vielleicht auch nicht. Deswegen, also ich glaube, deutlich ist, dass es nicht mehr ein System geben wird. Deutlich ist, es bewegt sich in Richtung von Versplitterung. Das heißt, es wird hier ein System geben, da ein Stadtstaat, hier Chaos, da gut funktionierende nationalstaat. Es wird, es wird allerhand Sachen nebeneinander geben. In dieser Zeit, dass alles ein System war, die bricht auf, die ist vorbei.
Also ich denke, dass der wesentliche Punkt, mit dem wir rechnen müssen, ist, wenn wir Russland so nehmen als Vorbild, wo es halt schon passiert ist, wo halt einfach die Strukturen zusammengebrochen sind und dann immer wieder so ein bisschen zusammengerauft wurden durch Putin und seine Bande da, dass der Punkt, nach dem sich die Leute sehen werden, ist Stabilität und Sicherheit.
Das heißt, wir kriegen auch einen starken Mann.
Das ist nicht zwingend gesagt. Das heißt, dass Systeme und Strukturen, die Stabilität und Sicherheit offerieren können, und die müssen nicht zwingend ein Polizeistadt sein, dass die wichtig sind und von Vorteil sind.
Ihr seid da besser geimpft als die meisten anderen. Ihr habt den Film schon mal gesehen hier in Deutschland. Das ist wichtig, weil sogar in Holland direkt nebenan merkt man, diese Leute haben den Film nicht gesehen. Für die holländische Kultur kam der Gefahr von außen, und das waren anderen und wir nicht. Wir Holländer ignorieren immer gerne, dass in Amsterdam mehr Juden nach Polen und Deutschland transportiert worden sind, als in Europa. Und dass das alles holländische Bullen waren, die das gerne gemacht haben. Deutschland hat da, glaube ich, aufgrund der Geschichte einen Vorsprung. Die Chancen hier, gerade weil die Energiepolitik jetzt richtig ist und man überall Windparks sieht, also mit Energie vielleicht 10, 20 Jahre mit weniger Stress zu rechnen ist als in manchen anderen Ländern. Und dass es diese Impfung stattgefunden hat, kulturelle Impfung, dass es sehr, sehr viele wissen, was passiert, wenn man einen starken Mann hinterherlauft. Ich glaube, Deutschland steht da gar nicht schlecht in dieser ganzen situation drin.
Wo ich ein bisschen hinaus wollte, war auch die Frage, Stabilität muss ja nicht immer starker Mann und Polizeistaat heißen. Das ist ja eben nicht der Fall, sondern Stabilität heißt ja erstmal primär. Lebensumstände, die sich nicht gravierend ändern, die halt hinreichend gut sind, dass die meisten Leute sie aushaltbar und okay finden und dass sie darin glücklich werden.
Ja, das mit dem glücklich werden ist auch wichtig. Ich glaube, dass es Stellen geben wird in Europa, nicht überall, aber es wird Stellen geben, wo es Leute sich selbst organisieren, wieder wissen, wo das Essen herkommt, zusammen Sachen tun, nicht individualisiert in irgendein Apartment sitzen und Fernsehen gucken und sich Pornoclicken, aber mit anderen Leuten zusammen wieder Sachen anfassen. Ich glaube, dass es viele Stellen in Europa gibt, wo das Leben für Individuen besser wird. Es wird auch Stellen geben, wo es schlechter wird, aber es wird auch Stellen geben, wo das Leben einfach besser wird.
Was wird denn unser Ziel sein, wenn wir nicht mehr Wachstum als Ziel haben?
Naja, ich meine, wir haben eine Menge zu reparieren.
Aber meinst du, wir werden dann so was wie Pursuit of Happiness kriegen als Ziel?
Gross national Happiness.
Das ist sowieso eingebaut. Also ich meine, das ist halt...
Naja, aber geht es dann mehr um... Wir müssen uns jetzt zusammen rauf. Also ich will darauf hin, es gibt jetzt eher so Krise, wir müssen uns jetzt retten, weil das ist ja ein starker Motivator, so Zusammenhalt.
Das Interessante ist, es wird halt alles, all das parallel geben. Es wird halt Strukturen geben, also Staaten oder auch Stadtstaaten, die dem chinesischen Modell folgen von der harmonischen Gesellschaft, die halt irgendwie die größtmögliche, Glück für die größtmögliche Zahl unter drastischer Einschränkung der individuellen Freiheiten. Es wird andere geben, bei denen der Individualismus wieder im Vordergrund stehen und die werden versuchen, halt so weiterzumachen. Und vielleicht wird es auch welche geben, die versuchen, irgendwie Individualismus und Wachstum zu entkoppeln.
Das große Problem ist Klimawandel. Das ist das einzige, was wirklich, wenn wir mal über so 100, 200 Jahre gucken, was versuchen zu gucken in die Zukunft, das einzige ist, wenn wir jetzt alle Öle und alle Kohle verbrennen, dann haben wir ein Problem. Wenn wir nicht eingreifen in co2-produktion, dann haben wir in 100 Jahren ein echtes Problem. Dann riskieren wir großflächigen Ecosystem-Collaps. Dafür brauchen wir einen, einen Humanity-übergreifenden Eingriff. Wir brauchen einen Effort, so wie es zum Beispiel im Zweiten Weltkrieg gegeben hat.
Das ist auch eine Sache, auf die ich noch hinauswarte.
Ohne Krieg, aber wir brauchen einen vergleichbaren Effort. Nicht einen militärischen Effort, sondern wir brauchen im Zweiten Weltkrieg nach Pearl Harbor hat Roosevelt einfach gesagt, wir bauen jetzt mal jahrelang keine Autos mehr. Weil wir brauchen die Factories, um Tanks und Schiffe zu bauen.
Wenn ich mir so Science fiction Literatur ansehe, die mit Kollaps zu tun hat, dann ist eigentlich immer die Vorhersage, dass es Kriege um die letzten Ressourcen geben wird. Rechnest du da auch mit? Also auch Ressourcen im Sinne von Himalaya ist nicht von der Wasserspiegel bedroht, deswegen kämpfen wir jetzt um die Berge oder auch so?
Also ich denke, dass das auf jeden Fall schon passiert. Also das ist das, was wir gerade sehen. Jetzt schon meinst du.
Die Wasserkriege bei Israel und so.
Ja, also die Wasserkriege um den Jordan werden jetzt die ersten sein, wo es vermutlich auch den Namen haben wird. Wir sehen die Kriege. Irak ist ein Ressourcenkrieg. Was immer da in Saudi-Arabien am Golf passiert, wird auch effektiv ein Ressourcenkrieg sein. Und wie lange Schwerwesteinwinde zu Edan noch auf seinem Öl so glücklich sitzen kann, ohne dass eben die Amis an den Kragen gehen.
Naja, der hat ja jetzt schon Krebs, ne?
Ja, naja, also es ist halt so, also die Auseinandersetzungen, die Ressourcen beginnen schon, in jedem Fall vor wahrscheinlich eher so als die 10, 15 Jahren. Und wir sehen es jetzt halt immer nur noch immer deutlicher. Ja, klar, es wird halt einfach mehr Kriege geben, davon können wir ausgehen, vermutlich nicht hier. Also Deutschland hat ja seine position klargemacht, wir haben halt irgendwie die russische Grasnadel im Arm und mit seinem Dealer stellt man sich halt gut. Und dementsprechend sieht halt auch die deutsche Außenpolitik aus.
Na, wir haben auch angesagt, dass wir für die Durchsetzung unserer wirtschaftlichen Interessen kriegführend wurden.
Ja klar, dass Köhler dafür noch zurücktreten musste, war eigentlich eher so ein bisschen komisch. Aber er hatte halt eigentlich ja de facto nur die aktuelle Bundeswehrdoktrin vorgelesen.
Ja, die schon lange in Betrieb war zu der Stelle.
Und diese, also dass militärische Auseinandersetzung ein Mittel zum Erhalt vom Status quo sein wird, für die reichen Länder des Nordens, ist klar. Auf der anderen Seite ist aber auch so, dass natürlich so eine militärische Auseinandersetzung ist eine verdammt ineffiziente Angelegenheit, um an Ressourcen zu gelangen. Also wenn man sich anguckt, wie viel die Amis da gerade im Irak und Afghanistan verballert haben, für relativ wenig effektiven Ölautput, den sie jetzt dafür bekommen.
Es hängt viel vom Klimawandel ab. Wenn Klimawandel jetzt in den nächsten 20, 30 Jahren so deutlich lebensbedrohend für alle Menschen wird, dass wir einsehen können, dass es uns einfach nicht mehr gibt in 30, 40 Jahren, wenn wir nicht alle zusammen was machen.
Naja, wobei.
Aber das ist natürlich in einer dezentrale Welt mit allerhanden Stadtstaaten und ist das viel schwieriger, als dass wir vor 20 Jahren oder 10 Jahren mal angefangen wären. Klar, wir haben da ein Problem.
Also im Irak geht es ja nicht tatsächlich darum, jetzt das Öl da zu fördern, sondern wer kontrolliert, wie viel Öl und wohin gefördert wird. Also ich denke, es geht auch bei den Rohstoffkriegen gar nicht darum, die Rohstoffe da jetzt rauszutragen, sondern langfristig den Fuß drauf zu haben. Deswegen kann es auch sein, dass man einen Krieg um Sachen führt, die noch gar nicht ein Problem sind.
Also die Frage ist, warum ist diese Krieg... Am Ende ist es halt ineffizient.
Natürlich, aber Krieg ist ja auch nicht eine Sache, mit der du anfängst, sondern Krieg machst du, wenn du siehst, oh Scheiße, wir haben die ganzen anderen optionen schon verpasst. Also wenn wir jetzt aussitzen...
Das bestreite ich einfach, weil es ist einfach so, dass wenn du eine große Militärmaschine in dir rumstehen hast, dann ist die zu benutzen aus verschiedenen Gründen interessante optionen. Du hältst deine Sponsoren aus der Rüstungsindustrie happy.
Ja gut, klar. Aber ich meine, was ich sagen will, ist, wenn wir jetzt weitermachen wie bisher und danach sieht es ja aus, dann merken wir halt in zehn Jahren, ja, dann gibt es halt keine option mehr außer Krieg, oder?
Siehst du das anders?
Also für die Regierung jetzt, nicht für uns als Menschheit, sondern wenn es die dann noch gibt, dann werden die Krieg führen, oder nicht?
Also meine persönliche Vermutung ist ja, dass die Vereinigten Staaten halt zerfallen werden. Also das ist halt einfach die, erstmal eine Weile mit sich selber zu tun haben werden.
Ja, es gibt ja noch andere Militärs, die da irgendwie noch ein bisschen...
Ja, aber die sind halt immerhin mit großem, weiten Abstand die größten.
Ja, klar.
So dass alle anderen... So und insofern ist der... Das Krieg ist sicherlich eine Sache, die nicht weggehen wird, die passieren wird, aber es wird eine lokalisierte Angelegenheit sein. Das wird hier und da passieren. Es wird irgendwie um spezifische Rohstoffe gehen, um spezifischen Zugang zu Wasser, um irgendwie das Aufbrechen von Marktblockaden, Seestraßen, Piraterie und so. Also das Militär wird halt sicherlich weiter wichtig bleiben, aber wenn wir uns die Militärbudgets angucken, die werden halt auch nicht mehr werden. Also da ist halt einfach nicht mehr viel mehr da. So ist das halt irgendwie...
Rechnest du mit irgendwelchen unglaublichen Flüchtlingsströmen dann, wenn sich rausstellt, oh, in dieser Gegend ist schlecht, da gibt es kein Wasser mehr oder so?
Da sind wir jetzt schon.
Naja, aber...
Also Somalia, Kenia, ist ja... Das wird, was damals vorher gesagt wurde, und es ist genau so, dass das jetzt passiert.
Ja, aber das kann man sich ja auch noch auf größere Ebene vorstellen. Und meinst du, das wird ein normales Bild sein einfach, dass ständig irgendwo riesige Menschenmengen am Fliehen sind?
Na klar. Aber die Frage ist ja für uns, was...
Genau, was machen wir denn jetzt konkret? Was geht denn weg? Wenn wir noch, also Flugzeuge werden wir nicht mehr haben, außer man ist superreich, aber was ist denn mit der Bahn? Und Autos. Meinst du, wir werden Elektroautos kriegen oder meinst du, das wird alles sterben?
Ich denke schon, dass es weiterhin die Möglichkeit für uns geben wird, sich individuell zu bewegen. So und wie auch immer die Transportsysteme aussehen werden. Einfach weil es zu... Es bremst einfach jegliche Entwicklung zu sehr aus, wenn es nicht geht. Mobilität ist so eingebaut in unsere Gesellschaft und sei es auch nur im lokalen Rahmen. Dass wir bereit sind, einen sehr hohen Preis für zu bezahlen, sowohl ökonomisch als auch ökologisch. Und wir haben eine Menge optionen, wie man es immer noch machen kann, selbst zu hohen Preisen, die dann halt vielleicht weniger individuell sind. Definitiv wird es nicht mehr so sein, dass du irgendwie als einzelner Person in deinem zweieinhalb Tonnen SUV irgendwie Wurzeln holen fahren kannst. Da wird dann vermutlich in der nächsten Ecke der Modell-Turfcocktail stehen.
Es hängt alles davon ab, wo du bist, wann und in wieviel Jahren. Da kann man so groß vielleicht gar nichts drüber sagen.
Ja, mich interessiert natürlich jetzt so Berlin. Welche Vorhersagen seht ihr für eine Großstadt wie Berlin? Wird es da irgendwie riots geben? Geht die Regierung von alleine platt, weil sie handlungsunfähig ist? Oder was glaubt ihr, was da passiert ist?
Das hängt immer von den Umständen ab.
Na ja, natürlich. Aber was seht ihr da so vor euch, wenn ihr die Augen zu macht und in den Himmel guckt?
Für Berlin kann ich da gerade einfach noch nicht viel sehen, außer dass die ökonomische Basis momentan nicht gegeben ist, außer Tourismus.
Der ist natürlich sofort weg, wenn Mobilität eingeschränkt ist.
Wenn Mobilität eingeschränkt ist, dann ist es halt mit dem Tourismus schwieriger. Oder vielleicht ist der Tourismus dann auch einfach nur ein ganz anderer. Vielleicht stellen Leute in den Zug und bleiben halt ein paar Wochen länger, kann ja auch sein.
Berlin hat ausreichend öffentliche Verkehrsmittel im Vergleich zu anderen Städten, die ganz wenig oder sogar gar nichts haben. Das ist schon mal gut. Berlin ist nicht in der Wüste, muss nicht irgendwie tonnenweise Energie ausgeben, um sich mit Wasser zu versorgen oder irgendwie kalt zu halten. Berlin ist nur im Winter ein paar Monate kalt.
Ist schon kein so schlechter Ort unter allen Dingen.
Ist schon kein so schlechter Ort. Genau, das würde ich auch so sagen.
Na gut, also jetzt gehen wir mal davon aus, dass wir hier...
Hat eine Strecke mit nicht so viele Leute drum rum, also hat Platz um sich herum.
Ja.
Liegt nicht in so einem suburban Wasteland, was zusammenfällt, weil die Leute da 30, 40 Kilometer fahren müssen. Individuell, um irgendwo zu kommen.
Also würdest du sagen, die Strukturen werden sich schon so erhalten, sagen wir mal im Scope Berlin? Oder sollte ich anfangen, mir einen kleinen Garten zu mieten, um mal selbst irgendwie Gebüse anzubauen? Oder sollte ich es auf jeden Fall tun?
Auf jeden Fall ist es keine schlechte Idee, sich optionen zu verschaffen.
Aber die option, die Gedanke, dass jeder jetzt in der Landwirtschaft muss.
Aber wir reden immer von dezentral und das ist ja schon...
Ja, aber dezentral kann auch sein, wenn es mal alles zusammenbricht oder teilweise zusammenbricht und es kommt zum Beispiel keine billig Plastik und Billig-Elektronik mehr aus China und aus überall, dann ist das die Fähigkeit, Sachen zu reparieren und die Fähigkeit, Sachen am Laufen zu halten und Sachen auseinanderzunehmen, überhaupt zu verstehen, wie sie funktionieren. Wie funktioniert die Lieferungskette einer Supermarkt? Durch wie viele Scheiß-Windows, SAP, das willst du gar nicht wissen, was da alles... Und wenn Sachen anfangen auseinanderzufallen, schwieriger zu werden, dezentraler zu werden, dann werden Leute gebraucht, die aus dieses Wasteland von Trottel gewartetem Scheiß irgendwas zu bauen, was noch funktioniert. Diese Leute werden Gold wert sein. Und Leute, die irgendwie verstehen, wie man das alles wieder zusammenbaut auf irgendwas, was noch geht. Ich glaube, das ist eine wichtige Rolle für Hacker.
Oder in der Lage sind, einen neuen Co zu schreiben, der irgendwie energieeffizienter ist und in der Lage ist, mit extrem heterogenen Hardware-Plattformen klarzukommen und solche Sachen.
Es wird noch lange dauern, bevor deine Fähigkeiten, technische Sachen irgendwie zu komprimieren und zu verstehen und außerhalb die Strukturen zu denken, weniger wert sind, als deine noch zu entstehende Fähigkeiten und irgendwas anzubauen.
Klar. Nein, aber ich meinte jetzt auch nicht, dass jeder einen kleinen Garten hat, sondern ich glaube, dass es höchstens einen Prozent der Bevölkerung gibt, die dieses Problem klar genug sehen, um da jetzt zu handeln. Und sollten die, die dann die pioniere sein werden, weil die die Ersten sind, die überhaupt vorbereitet sind, was sollten die denn haben?
Frank und ich haben angesprochen, was für Hacker...
So eine kleine Community grinden, wo mit verteilten diversen Fähigkeiten.
Was jetzt wichtig ist, während es alles noch geht und alles noch prima aussieht eigentlich, was jetzt wichtig ist, ist, dass wir anfangen, drüber nachzudenken, was die Dependencies sind. Dass wir anfangen nachzudenken, was könnte jetzt am Ersten schiefgehen und was machen wir, wenn das passiert? Also Fallback-Szenarien ausdenken. Wer jetzt Zeit investieren möchte und sich mal hinsetzen möchte, so die erste paar Jahre ist, was fehlt? Was sind die Fallback-Szenarien? Und wie halten wir das am Laufen? Weil man muss nicht direkt von die heutige situation auf nichts, das haben wir Binary Thinking genannt. Die Gedanke, entweder alles geht noch und alles prima und mein Gmail tut es noch und Google tut es noch, alles funktioniert oder alles ist weg, alles ist tot und wir müssen jetzt auf Landwirtschaft umschalten und wir müssen einzeln mit meinem AK 47 ins Wald rein. Die höchste Wahrscheinlichkeit ist, dass es irgendwo dazwischen liegt. Und umso länger wir Sachen am Laufen halten, umso länger haben mehr Leute Zeit, um nachzudenken.
Würdest du da sagen, dass wir priorisieren müssen und sagen, na gut, also das System, das vergessen wir gleich mal, das können wir eh nicht retten.
Genau.
Also jetzt Gedanken machen, was wir haben wollen, was wir wirklich haben wollen.
Was wichtig ist.
Genau und da habt ihr gedacht, telekommunikation war euch wichtig.
Ja, telekommunikation wird immer wichtig sein.
Ja und deswegen ist der Vorschlag in eurem Vortrag gewesen, dass wir versuchen, Telekom Equipment zu bunkern, von dem wir wissen, dass es funktioniert und dass wir es reparieren können, wenn es kaputt geht.
Ja, dass wir versuchen, Levels zu definieren, worauf wir runter können, wenn der Komplexität mal nicht da ist. Gegeben, es gibt mal, weil alles hat jetzt Abhängigkeiten miteinander. Wenn mal kein GPS-Signal, weil jemand einen GPS-Jammer hat, dann geht mal das ganze Telefonnetz nicht, weil die alle eher ein Timing davon haben oder wenn diese ganzen Abhängigkeiten mal runterschrauben und mal definieren, was sind Levels, worauf wir zurückschalten können.
Das ist übrigens zu GPS, würde ich gerne noch sagen, dass die Leute so die Idee haben, das sind halt Satelliten, die sind da oben und die bleiben da jetzt. Und da können wir auch in 100 Jahren noch GPS mitmachen. Das stimmt nicht, sondern die müssen halt regelmäßig replaced werden.
Und die müssen nachgesteuert werden.
Genau, das heißt aber jedenfalls, wenn man die einfach da jetzt lässt, dann sind die, die haben eine Lebenszeit und nach der stürzen sie sich in die Atmosphäre und verglühen. Also das heißt, wenn wir jetzt wirklich einen Kollaps haben, ist GPS auch irgendwann weg.
Na ja, also wie gesagt, dass die Sowjetin bzw. Russland halt mal ein schönes Beispiel hat, man gesehen, wie lange so Infrastruktur durchhält, wenn niemand sich mehr drum kümmert. Und das ist halt eben auch...
Das war erschütternd lange, ne?
Ja, weil sie halt dafür gebaut wurde.
Also du meinst, unsere Infrastruktur ist irgendwie darauf ausgelegt, dass sie immer repariert werden muss, weil wir ja hier eine Wachstumswirtschaft haben.
Und da gibt es halt dieses schöne Buch in präsentation von dem Dmitri Orlov mit dem schönen Namen Closing the Collapse Gap, der sich mal angeguckt hat, wie denn so die sowjetische Wirtschaft funktionierte, nachdem da irgendwie alles ein bisschen zusammenbrach und wie es möglicherweise in den USA sein wird. Er hat ein paar interessante Sachen aufgelistet, zum Beispiel, dass so ein Suburbier-Vorort-Lifestyle halt echt schwierig wird, weil es halt einfach keine, naja, da ist halt nichts. Also da gibt es halt irgendwie keine Möglichkeiten zum Einkaufen. Und der hat halt dann auch darüber nachgedacht, wie es mit der Transportinfrastruktur ist. Und Transportinfrastruktur ist ja inhärent eine Sache, die sehr individualisiert ist und dann soll es dann nun halt nicht wahr sein. Da gibt es halt Eisenbahnen, die sind halt gebaut worden, dafür, dass sie 20 Jahre waren. So ohne, dass da noch signifizierter Warterehrung in Deutschland ist, zum Beispiel die ICEs, da habe ich gar nicht zweifelt. Ich meine, das ist halt so ein...
Wie ist denn da die Quote in Russland eigentlich gewesen? Wie viele Leute haben da ein Auto gehabt? Das war eben nur ganz wenig.
Ja, war wenig. Aber die Eisenbahnen waren halt solide, die fuhren halt langsam, die fuhren halt, die fuhren halt immer. So möglicherweise fuhren sie nicht nach Fahrplatten, aber du kamst halt irgendwie von A nach B mit deinem kopfvoller Hühnervent sein musst du so. Und wenn sie dir dagegen so die...
Also Stabilität auf Deutsch.
Ja, Stabilität, genau. Und wenn ich mir hingegen angucke, was die Deutsche Bahn tut, wo so ein ICE einfach wirklich jeden Abend in die Werkstatt muss. So und irgendwie nach 3000 Kilometern oder so müssen die da die Räder röntgen und irgendwie Ersatzteile ranflanschen und so. Das ist halt eben dieser Preis der Geschwindigkeit. Wenn du halt irgendwie 250 kmh fahren willst, dann heißt das eben, dass du halt intensiv warten musst, dass du halt irgendwie viele Ersatzteile brauchst. Wenn du halt irgendwie damit leben kannst, dass du mit 85 kmh durch die Gegend schuckelst und halt lieber auf jeden Nachzug. Naja, es dauert dann halt lange, aber du kommst halt wenigstens hin und irgendwie dafür kannst du halt den Wagen so bauen, dass alle bewegten Teile halt irgendwie nur mal ein bisschen geschmiert werden müssen und dann geht's weiter. Aber das ist ja eben momentan nicht die Philosophie und das ist halt so ein Ding, was wir halt als Resilience bezeichnet haben. Also als Möglichkeit, Stabilität einfach durch technische Umstände zu schaffen, die hinterher immer noch funktionieren.
Was hältst du denn von so selbst reparierenden Systemen?
Was man zu selbst reparieren?
Na also das ist so ein Trend, den man ganz gerne sieht, dass die Leute noch mehr Komplexität in so ein System reintun mit der Idee, dass sich das irgendwie selbst heilt. Das ist so ein Stichwort, was gerade total das Buzzword ist in der IT. Dass man halt irgendwie Systeme redundant auslegt und da Software dazutut oder irgendwie eine Logik dazutut, die dann quasi dafür sorgt, dass es am Leben hält. Also ich spreche das an, weil meine Erfahrung eben eher ist, dass es nicht funktioniert. Das weiß man nicht eher seit Asimov. Der hat ja diese schöne foundation-geschichte erzählt mit den selbst reparierenden Atomkraftwerken, die dann halt irgendwie tausend Jahre funktioniert haben und nach den tausend Jahren ging die dann der Reihe nach kaputt und da gab es keinen mehr, der wusste, wie man sie reparieren soll.
Weil die sich halt alle selber reparieren.
Genau, weil das brauchte man eben nicht, das Wissen. Und dann ging es halt verloren. Und gut, tausend Jahre wird das jetzt nicht dauern bei uns, aber ich sehe diesen Trend mit Sorge. Die Idee, dass wir noch mehr kommen.
Es gibt jetzt schon ein bisschen, was verloren geht.
Was denn so?
In unserer Community, wir sind schon immer weniger, jedes Jahr weniger Leute, wie man eine Mail-Server betreibt.
Weil die alles zu Gmail gehen.
Weil die alles zu Gmail gehen. Weil immer mehr von was wir täglich benutzen, aus der Cloud kommt, wo kein Open Source Software hinten rausfällt, wo nicht noch ein Apache-Projekt oder noch ein Postfix oder noch so Sachen hinten rausfallen, die man dann benutzen kann und auch ein Dezentral, sondern wo irgendwelche Engineers bei Google oder irgendwelche Engineers demnächst bei Apple sich Services bauen, die wir alle benutzen und wo eigentlich was übrig bleibt, sind MacJobs, sind die Leute, die noch Cisco und DSLAMs anschließen können und Sachen zusammenwerfen können und noch ein bisschen Routing, damit alles möglichst schnell die Bits nach Amerika kommen, da wo unsere Services laufen.
Das ist auch so ein Hardware-Trend. Also nicht nur bei Services, sondern auch bei der Hardware ist es so, wenn man heute ein Notebook aufschraubt und da ist irgendwas kaputt, dann gibt es so drei Teile, die man tauschen kann. Es gibt das Mainboard, da ist im Grunde alles drauf. Dann gibt es die Festplatte, die kann man noch rausnehmen, vielleicht die Ram-Riegel. Bei den billigen Netbooks kann man teilweise schon die Ram-Riegel nicht mehr rausnehmen. Und das Display. Und wenn man was repariert, dann tauschen die das Mainboard aus. Dann wird er nicht mehr gelötet, weil das einfach nicht vorgesehen ist. Und das ist auch so eine Sache, die man eigentlich mit Sorge sehen muss. Das ist überhaupt nicht nachhaltig. Und dieses Wissen, wie man sowas repariert, ist dann auch futsch.
Na und du kriegst halt im Zweifel die Ersatzteile nicht mehr. Also heute schon so, weil die Geräte dann nicht mehr am Markt sind und auch keine Ersatzteile mehr geliefert werden. Und es wird zukünftig halt so sein, weil die Hersteller einfach pleite gehen und nicht mehr da sind.
Na und weil das alles on demand gefertigt wird und nicht mit Waren, Lagern. Das ist ja schon bei Supermärkten. Das habt ihr ja auch in den Slides angesprochen, dass die so eine Lagerfrist von irgendwie so einen Tag haben. Also je nach Gut natürlich. Aber wenn mal irgendein Problem bei der Zustellung ist, weil immer viel Schnee gefallen ist oder eine Autobahn gesperrt ist, weil ein Trucker platzt ist, dann kann das durchaus sein, dass so ein Supermarkt mal das eine oder andere Gut nicht mehr da hat. Weil die einfach täglich angeliefert werden. So täglich. Und der Supermarkt selbst hat ein Lager, was überhaupt nicht ausreicht, um da irgendwie Vorrat zu haben. Und das ist eben bei Hardware auch so. Das wird alles on demand gefertigt. Das ist so das Optimierungsstichwort schlechthin seit irgendwie 2000 oder so. Alles lean und schlank und keine Fetten mehr.
Geht bei Autos auch schon 20, 30 Jahre genauso. Du kannst selber keine Autos mehr reparieren. Du brauchst das Software-Paket und Hardware-Dings, was nur an Peugeot, Renault oder Audi-Garagen geliefert wird.
Aber das ist ja protektionismus und nicht Effizienzsteigerung.
Was es ist, ist egal. Wenn dein Auto kaputt ist und die Infrastruktur ist gebrochen, dann kannst du es immer noch nicht reparieren.
Also einer der Dinge, die ich sehr interessant fand, im Vergleich so Osten früher und Westen zur selben Zeit oder auch dann jetzt, früher gab es im Osten eigentlich zu jedem Elektronikgerät einen Schaltplan. Der lag einfach dabei, der war Teil des Handbuches.
Ich habe gehört, dass es in, ich weiß jetzt nicht mehr, ob das Polen war, oder also jedenfalls eins der Nachbarländer im Osten, dass du da überhaupt kein Gerät verkaufen konntest, weil die Leute darauf bestanden haben, dass der Plan bei liegt, damit es repariert werden kann.
Das ist tatsächlich so.
Und hier gab es das auch mal, habe ich gehört, das war wohl vor meiner Zeit, ich habe das jedenfalls nie bewusst wahrgenommen, dass wenn du so ein Fernseher gekauft hast, es auch noch ein Schaltplan bei war.
Im Westen war das teilweise auch so, aber in den 70ern.
Das ist lange weg, ja, lange vorbei.
Aber ich habe noch Fernseher repariert, wo es noch drin war, ja.
Cool, tja, die zweiten sind vorbei, das ist alles integrierte Elektronik. Aber das ist auch unsere Bildungspflicht als Hacker, dass wir dafür sorgen, dass wir es nicht verloren gehen. Und dass wir an Loot-Workshops auf dem Camp teilnehmen, um uns beizubringen, wie man im Notfall so einen Chip wechseln kann.
Stimmt, Fefe hat Löten gelernt.
Naja, wir sollen nicht zu weit gehen hier.
Also die interessante Überschneidung ist ja eben auch, dass wir sagen, bei solchen Geräten wie iPad und ähnlichem, dass wir eigentlich wollen, dass uns dieses Gerät gehört, also dass wir es halt programmieren können. Und eigentlich müssen wir diese Forderung erweitern, dass wir es reparieren können. Und sei es halt auch nur Component-Level-Repair, also dass wir halt z.B. Chips austauschen, aber dass es halt einfach eine Möglichkeit gibt, überhaupt was dran zu tun. In den allermeisten Fällen sind halt die Probleme, die bei solchen Geräten auftauchen, eh Stromversorgung oder relativ simple Sachen, oder Kontaktprobleme, wo du halt einfach wenigstens wissen musst, in welcher Ecke des Mainboards du gucken musst. Und da sind wir halt, denke ich mal, am Anfang von so einer Forderungskette, wo du sagen musst, okay, es geht halt nicht nur darum, dass das Gerät meins ist, was ich gekauft habe, sondern dass es halt auch weiter benutzen will, wenn euch der Laden schon in die Ohren geflogen ist. Die andere Sache, die wir hatten, war diese Resilience Conspiracy, wo wir gesagt haben, okay, wir sollten einfach als Leute, die in technischen Berufen arbeiten, anfangen darüber nachzudenken, was passiert denn dann? So und wenn irgendwie die Firma pleite geht, wie kriegt man dann die Infrastruktur noch weiter betrieben?
Auch wenn ich weg bin, wenn ich weg bin, wie kann man die Infrastruktur, die ich gerade aufbaue, so aufbauen, dass sie ein bisschen mehr aushält, als gefordert ist?
Ja, bzw. hinterher auch wieder bootbar ist, also dass man sie überhaupt wieder an den Start bekommt. Das heißt also, dass die dokumentation da ist, dass man eine minimalkonfiguration hat, die z.B. eben nur das technisch Notwendige tut. Also wenn wir z.B. mal so eine asp-konfiguration nehmen, dann kann ich auf diesen ganzen Billingscheiß komplett verzichten. Und ich muss möglicherweise halt auch...
Und auf Lawful interception.
Und Lawful interception und irgendwie solche Sachen, wie Bevorzugung von diesem oder jedem Streaming Service, sind nicht erforderlich. So interessant ist eben eine minimalkonfiguration zu haben, die auch dokumentiert ist, mit der man wenigstens dafür sorgen kann, dass die Bits fließen. Und das gibt es halt an ganz vielen anderen Stellen auch so. Also ein Beispiel, was ich in dem Talk hatte, war einfach Sachen nicht wegschmeißen, wenn man weiß, dass sie funktionieren. Also zum Beispiel war so ein Ding in so einem Dorf, da war eine Hochwasserzone, oder? Dieses Dorf ist dadurch gerettet worden, dass der Feuerwehrhauptmann, der alte, hat so eine sowjetische Super-Ultra-Monster-Pumpe aufgehoben, die die wegschmeißen wollten.
Aus Nostalgiegründen?
Nee, weil man wusste halt, dass sie irgendwann brauchen wird. Die wurden halt an der Oder und das hat manchmal Hochwasser. Dann haben die zwei neue Pumpen bekommen und die sind auch wesentlicher leistungsfähiger, was die Größe zur Pumpleistung angeht. Aber mit so einem Monster-Truck-Pumpsystem, was darauf ausgelegt ist, einfach auf der Lage zu laufen, schaffst du halt extrem viel weg und hat das Dorf gerettet. So, dass er die aufgehoben hat. Solche Sachen werden wir halt häufiger brauchen. Einfach vorausdenken, überlegen, okay, was passiert, wenn dieses und jenes System failt? Wenn es ausfällt, dann kann ja auch mal sein, dass es nur für ein paar Stunden fällt, dass einfach der Strom ausfällt. Die einfachsten Sachen sind zum Beispiel, fragt doch mal nach bei einem Dienstleister, wenn ihr zum Beispiel im Rechenzentrum arbeitet, fragt doch mal nach, ob der Dienstleister, der den Diesel nach 48 Stunden für den Notstromaggregate, wenn der Diesel-Tank auf dem Gelände alle ist, liefern soll, ob der auch liefern kann, wenn alle seine Kunden gleichzeitig danach fragen. Was halt passieren kann, wenn mal für drei Tage der Strom ausfällt und diese ganzen Notstromgeneratoren eben nicht nur einer es braucht, weil jemand Scheiße am Schaltschrank gebaut hat, sondern wenn einfach mal der Strom ausfällt.
So ein bisschen ein Nachteil sehe ich ja schon mit der Idee, dass wir jetzt hier versuchen, alles resilient zu bauen, weil dadurch stützen wir ein System, was spart. Weil wenn wir dafür sorgen, dass es länger hält, als die Speck es eigentlich hergibt, dann werden die die Speck eben noch löchriger machen.
Das muss man halt an ihnen vorbeimachen. Deswegen heißt es Conspiracy. Also so, dass sie es halt nicht wissen.
Meinst du nicht, die merken das? Oh, wir haben aber wenig Ausfälle, da können wir noch sparen.
Der Boss muss es ja nicht wissen.
Achso, du meinst, du schaltest dann auch nicht an, damit irgendwie die Feedback behalten bleibt?
Du sorgst nicht dafür, dass kurzfristige Sachen, die dazu führen könnten, dass du eben noch mehr Reserve wegkattest, benutzt dann halt deinen heimlichen Backup-Generator nicht. diskredition. Zum anderen ist es halt auch so, dass es durchaus auch hilft in solchen Fällen, dann halt einfach zu sagen, pass auf, wir haben hier gerade nur überlebt, weil da noch ein Generator in der Ecke stand, von dem du nicht wusstest und den auch nicht bezahlen wolltest. Aber das führt dann halt häufiger einfach dazu, zu Denkprozessen passieren. Und aus diesem Effizienzwahn herauszukommen und einfach zu verstehen, dass gerade diese ganze Just-in-Time-Logik halt nicht dazu führt, dass wir ja lang fast die Stabilität haben werden, der Prozess wird vermutlich sehr schnell gehen. Also die assoziation von Just-in-Time mit Instabilität, ich denke, da wird es nur wenige Krisenzyklen brauchen, bis das soweit klar ist.
Ist ja jetzt schon klar. Also man sieht ja in den Medien immer, dass die vom Jahrhundert-Winter reden, wenn mal wieder alles zusammenrückt. Wie viele Jahrhundert-Web-Event sich schon jetzt in den... Das geht gar nicht. Und das ist ja alles diese Just-in-Time-Scheiße. Die haben halt hier gespart und da gespart und da noch ein bisschen gespart. Und daraus ergibt sich eben Instabilität. Und das ist natürlich nicht nur Just-in-Time, sondern das ist auch... Ach, können wir hier nicht vielleicht das billigere Fett nehmen, um die Schienen zu pflegen? Na klar, aber das ist ja derselbe Hintergrund, diese ganze Effizienzscheiße. Und dann hört man nämlich, dass sie irgendwie die fetten Boni auszahlen und Dividende zahlen können, weil sie so toll Profit gemacht haben. Und da muss man halt mal gegensteuern.
Also eine Sache, über die wir noch reden sollten, sind Cloud-Services. Die hatten wir schon mal kurz angerissen, die halt immer hipper werden. Und Rob hat da einen schönen Vergleich gefunden, nämlich, dass so ein Cloud-Service so ein bisschen ist wie Walmart. Vielleicht magst du die noch mal kurz erzählen?
Naja, das hab ich, glaub ich, gerade auch gemacht. Es entstehen... Das mit dem Walmart muss man noch kurz erklären. Außerhalb der großen Städten oder der kleineren Städten in Amerika kommen jetzt diesen Big-Box-Stores wie Walmart. Und die verkaufen alles billiger als jeder, das innerhalb dieser Stadt kann. Großer Parkplatz, außerhalb, Leute fahren hin, kaufen sich...
Haben halt weniger Miete und so, und können ihren Strombrück kaufen und kriegen das halt...
Genau, kaufen eine Milliarde davon in China, anstatt nur ein paar. Und das höhlt die lokale Wirtschaft aus. Die lokale Wirtschaft wird davon kleiner. Es bleiben Mac-Jobs übrig, Leute, die in Temporary Contracts für wenig Geld bei solchen Chainstores arbeiten.
Zeitarbeiten nimmt man das bei uns. Auch ein ganz toller Trend, der ja... der eigentlich nie populär war, bis sie gemerkt haben, dass sie das benutzen können, um die Arbeitslosenstatistik zu schönen. Und seitdem ist das hier super populär bei den Politikern.
Okay, und?
Und weiter?
Naja, meine Gedanke ist eigentlich, dass die Cloud-Services für unsere Community dasselbe sind. Die Cloud-Services nehmen aus unserer Communitys Fähigkeiten weg, wie zum Beispiel gerade angesprochen mit dem Mail-Server. Und was übrig bleibt ist nur, so viel wie möglich Kabel anschließen, Modems anschließen, damit wir alle schnell unsere Cloud-Services aus Amerika nutzen können.
Das kann man beobachten, also das glaube ich auch.
Und der Effekt ist ja dann genau derselbe wie im Kollapsfall, wie wenn so ein Bigbox-Store seine Logistik nicht mehr in den Griff bekommt. Also dass du nichts mehr zu essen hast.
Und man muss auch sagen, dass Google's Geschäftsmodell auf Werbung basiert. Und die Werbung basiert darauf, dass wir einen globalisierten Markt haben. Und der ist weg, wenn wir anfangen mit dem teuren Öl. Das heißt, dass die Idee, dass Gmail spontan platzen könnte, ist gar nicht so abwegig, wie es jetzt vielleicht klingt.
Ja, eben genau die Frage, ob Geschäftsmodelle, die auf Werbung und Datenverwertung beruhen, wie lange die überhaupt noch funktionieren, ist natürlich direkt abhängig davon, wie viel Geld die Leute noch haben für irgendwelchen Kram kaufen, für den man Werbung schalten kann. Und es kann dann im Zweifelfall auch sehr schnell gehen, dass die halt irgendwann nicht mehr verfügbar sind, weil die Werbeennahmen drastisch einbrechen. Ja, eine Sache, die wir noch nicht vergessen sollten, ist in jedem Fall, wenn man sich jetzt fragt, was kann man eigentlich tun? Also wo sollte man jetzt so seine Zeit rein investieren? Wir hatten ja vorhin erwähnt, dass das lokale Abgleiten in Polizeistaaten doch ziemlich wahrscheinlich ist. Also das ist halt einfach der staatlichere, direktere Kontrollregime, die die Freiheit des Einzelnen einschränken, unter dem Versprechen, dass es uns allen besser geht, wenn sich der Einzelne einschränkt und unterwirft. Die werden halt kommen und die sind natürlich dazu geneigt, politischen Fortschritt zu unterbinden und irgendwie nicht weiter durchgehen zu lassen. Und wenn wir halt trotzdem, ja, sagen wir mal, politische Freiheiten haben wollen, brauchen wir halt die Werkzeuge. Das heißt also, wenn man jetzt gerade überhaupt nicht weiß, was man tun soll, oder wie kein Bock hat, sich einen kleinen Karten zu kaufen, weil es sowieso nichts nutzt.
Und das kann gut fliebsicher sein.
Infrastruktur, das stimmt richtig. Und Infrastruktur zu schwierig, findet, dann kann man immer noch seine Energie da reinstecken, halt Werkzeuge zu entwickeln, mit denen man hinterher immer noch kommunizieren kann. Also zum Beispiel halt sowas wie Toa oder Itopi, Anonymisierungstools, sichere Mail, kleine Chatlines, Telefone, kollaborationstools. Weil wir können definitiv davon ausgehen, dass man die nächsten twitter-revolutionäre erkennt, man halt irgendwie an dem Einschussloch zwischen den Augen und nicht mehr daran, dass sie irgendwie plötzlich Minister geworden sind. Das war ein einmaliger Unfall, der so nicht wieder passieren wird, wie wir jetzt auch in Großbritannien sehen. Und es heißt also, sich da zu engagieren, wenn man die technischen Fähigkeiten hat oder auch Designfähigkeiten, ist in jedem Fall eine gute Idee. Eine andere Sache, die man in jedem Fall tun sollte, ist informationen, die man wichtig findet, also die halt einen Wert haben in dem Sinn, dass sie sich zum Beispiel in How-To sind oder so was, dass man die eben aufheben muss.
Das müssen wir jetzt bunkern. Also nicht nur bunkern, sondern natürlich auch weiter verteilen. Aber es gibt einen Schatz an Wissen, der im Moment nicht weiter eine Rolle spielt, der aber in Zukunft eine Rolle spielen wird. Und dann sollte man jetzt schon anfangen, sich da anzueignen, was geht. Aber man sollte, wenn man die Zeit nicht hat, dann sollte man jetzt schon anfangen, sich die Bücher zuhauten oder die E-Books oder was weiß ich, wo man das am besten halt sich herholt. Aber E-Books sind natürlich am billigsten zu bunkern, aber auch Marktbetrachter.
Ja, aber wir sollten uns halt nicht übersehen, dass irgendwie ein Großteil der Leute, die halt irgendwie aus dem Internet ihr Leben bestreiten, im Sinne von Lebenshinweis holen, sie benutzen halt YouTube-How-To's. Gigabyte und Gigabyte YouTube-How-To's. Und ob die denn noch da sind, wenn die Werbung wegbricht.
Das ist auch eine Cloud.
Ja, das ist auch eine Cloud, genau. Und da halt eben Sachen aufzuheben, die man wichtig findet und zu archivieren und zu tauschen, ist eine extrem wichtige Sache. Also wenn man Kram kauft, also wenn man sich jetzt mal wieder noch ein paar Euros zu verbrennen hat.
Neues Dollar-Gerät.
Dann sollte man in jedem Fall daran denken, dass man eher Werkzeuge als Spielzeug kauft. Also eher Sachen kauft, mit denen man Sachen am Laufen halten kann, reparieren kann und dass man auch daran denkt, wenn man sich neue Sachen kauft, ob man die später nochmal repariert bekommt oder ob die Freunde die repariert bekommen. Also ob es halt einfach einen Match gibt zwischen den Fähigkeiten, die nötig sind, um so ein Gerät längerfristig am Laufen zu halten und dem, was tatsächlich da ist. Und dann vielleicht doch eher lieber das kaufen, was halt ein bisschen längerfristige Haltbarkeit hat.
Vorbei bei Computern und Notebooks ist die Zeit, glaube ich, vorbei, wo man dann noch irgendwas reparieren kann. Da müssen wir echt anfangen, uns selber unsere Prozessoren zusammen zu synthetisieren. Das gibt es ja auch Leute, die das hier auf dem Camp oder anderswo machen. Das ist ein wichtiger Punkt. Dahin müssen wir hinkommen, dass wir uns unsere Hardware zur Not auch selber nachbauen können. Im Moment können wir nur einen Knopf klicken und dann liefert uns die jemand. Und das ist keine Nachhaltigkeit, wenn wir in der Zukunft noch Computer haben wollen nach einem eventuellen Collapse oder was auch immer, wenn Shipping aus China teuer wird. Das ist in Wirtschaftskreisen im Moment, da wird das hochgehalten als der größte Vorteil Deutschlands, dass wir uns die Industrie im Land gehalten haben.
Und nicht, wie die Briten irgendwie alles durch die finanzielle Industrie ersetzt haben.
Und nicht genau alles zu Banken gewandelt haben. Und das heißt selbst jetzt, wo sich herausstellt, dass Öl teuer wird plötzlich und überraschend, da haben wir immer noch Know-how im Land, um Dinge zu bauen. Und das müssen wir ausbauen. Das müssen wir auf Computer ausbauen, denn Computer sind wichtig. Und wir wollen auch in Zukunft Computer haben. Dann müssen wir eben gucken, dass wir auch das Know-how haben, um die selber zu bauen.
Solange noch ziemlich viel Kram da ist.
Solange man da ist, sollte man gucken, dass man die Sachen, die wiederverwertbar sind, auch wiederverwertet. Und eben solche Sachen kauft, die auch wiederverwertbar sind.
Und zwar bevor die Leute, die nachts losziehen und die Kupferkabel aus dem Boden buddeln, sich die holen.
Das passiert ja auch nur so lange, als würde es passieren, wenn du hier jemanden kaufst. Und wenn hier keine produktion stattfindet und Shipping nach China zu teuer wird, dann wird auch der Rohstoffdiebstahl aufhören. Denn was willst du dann machen mit dem Kupfer?
Naja, bist du sicher? Also ich meine, wenn die produktion hier wieder losgeht, dann wird es mit dem Rohstoffdiebstahl...
Ja, das muss erst mal geschehen, ne?
Auf irgendeinem Level wird das schon passieren. Und wenn es irgendwie ist, dass die Leute Kupfer einschmelzen, um keine Ahnung, sich Telefonen dreht, fürs Feldtelefon zu ziehen oder so. Also das ist halt ganz schön passiert.
Also wir haben die Community ja schon angesprochen, die man sich da bilden muss. Das ist ein Punkt, den wir noch mal sagen wollen, dass so Freunde sind wichtig, dass man Leute kennt.
Und zwar die richtigen, nicht die auf Facebook.
Und nicht nur virtuelle Leute, die man irgendwie im Internet gesehen hat, sondern dass man sich tatsächlich mal kennt, dass man weiß, wie der aussieht, dass man ihm die Hand gedrückt hat, dass man sich auch zusammensetzt, was zusammen ist und trinkt und redet. Und dass man für Notfälle weiß, auf wen man zurückfallen kann, wenn man ein Problem hat. Und dass man versucht, so Kreise zu bauen, die möglichst viel abdecken von dem, was ist da an...
Viele unterschiedliche Fähigkeiten, genau.
Was man vielleicht brauchen kann, dass man halt guckt zu möglichst allem, was man so braucht, die man zu kennen. Und dann ist man krisenfest.
Oder zumindest krisenfester als die Nachbarn.
Ja, also das ist natürlich der nächste Punkt. Was machen wir mit den ganzen unvorbereiteten Nachbarn, die dann zu uns kommen und ihre Hardware repariert haben wollen?
Deswegen sag ich ja, dass...
Und die sich irgendeinen Ranz gekauft haben, den man nicht mehr reparieren kann.
Na gut, aber das hat dann die Frage halt eben, wie funktioniert denn die Wirtschaft? Also welche...
Das macht man dann über den Preis, meinst du?
Welche Dienstleistungen sind dann halt noch die interessanten Dienstleistungen und Sachen drin reparieren können und wieder ans Laufen bringen? Oder auch Systeme aus irgendwie komischen, heterogenen Komponenten zusammen integrieren können, ist in jedem Fall eine extrem wertvolle Fähigkeit. Also auch improvisieren zu können ist halt eine Sache, die wir ganz gut können.
Lernt Pearl.
Oder Pysen oder was auch immer. Na gut, also sich mit den richtigen Leuten zu umgeben, ist in jedem Fall die wichtigste Sache. Und zwar mit den richtigen Freunden, nicht nur Facebook. Die es einem ermöglicht im Zweifel halt aus kritischen situationen halt einfach irgendwie rauszukommen, weil man jemanden kennt, der einem helfen kann. Egal wie die situation ist. Und das ist halt nicht nur Leute, die halt irgendwie Hardware können, sondern auch Leute, die Medizin können, die kochen können. Die wissen im Zweifel, wie man ja handelt. Oder auch Leute, die halt irgendwie mit Leuten mal reden können, wenn halt irgendwie die situation ein bisschen komisch wird. So, da gibt es halt...
Na und auch, dass man einfach weiß, auf die man sich verlassen kann, wenn die Scheiße am Dampfen ist.
Das ist das Allerwichtigste. Das sind möglicherweise eben nicht die Leute, mit denen man am liebsten zusammenhängt. Weil sie vielleicht im Sozialen nicht so ganz angenehm sind. Aber eben, wenn es Leute sind, auf die man sich verlassen kann, dann wird man in solchen situationen eher dann doch mit denen rumhängen. Ja gut.
Also jetzt ganz konkret...
Zusammenfassen.
Ganz konkret, was mache ich denn ab morgen? Ich gehe los, kaufe mir E-Books über Reparatur von Kühlschränken.
Wenn du findest, dass Kühlschränke reparieren dein Crawling ist, aber ich glaube eher, dass du andere Fähigkeiten hast, auf die du nicht zurückziehen solltest.
Ja gut.
Also am Ende geht es ja darum, dass man seine persönlichen...
Na ja, dass man was findet, woran man Spaß hat.
Genau, das sind wir wieder bei diesem Happiness-Ding. Also das ist halt einfach, wenn wir Sachen machen, die uns Spaß machen, auch wenn es jetzt nicht das ist, wofür wir gerade in der jetzigen Ökonomie am meisten Geld bekommen, diese Fähigkeiten nicht schleifen zu lassen, sondern die zu entwickeln, das ist halt das eigentlich Wichtige. Also Sachen, die nützlich sind und Spaß machen, sind genau das, worum es geht. Auch wenn sie möglicherweise Tätigkeiten sind, die heute in China viel billiger gemacht werden können, möglicherweise sind es halt Sachen, die demnächst nicht mehr am billigsten in China gemacht werden können oder einfach nicht mehr in der Zeit. Und solche Sachen zu können und zu pflegen, solches Wissen, ist, denke ich mal, die allerbeste Vorbereitung und die richtigen Freunde haben.
Also eignet euch das Wissen an, dass ihr brauchen werdet, wenn der Transport aus China sich nicht mehr lohnt.
Genau. So, und dann...
Ja, diese Resilience-Conspiracy.
Nehmt an ihr teil.
Nehmt an ihr teil. Baut... Resistance oder Resilience in die Netze ein.
Speichert auch...
Speichert Hardware.
Beschäftigt euch mit Technologien. Ja, also das ist einer der Gründe, warum wir zum Beispiel zum Camp kommen. Weil man hier sehen kann, wie so ein WLAN eigentlich gebaut wird.
Oder so ein GSM-Netzwerk.
Oder GSM-Netzwerk, ja. Also das ist ein Punkt auch, den ihr gemacht habt, bei dem Vortrag, den ich hier nochmal explizit rausziehen will. Bei Landwirtschaft wissen wir, auf was wir zurückfallen können, bevor es den Ölboom gab. Bei Telco nicht. Das gab es eigentlich noch nicht, als es das Öl noch nicht gab. Und da müssen wir gucken.
Auch das Telco, was es als ersten gegeben hat, darauf wollen wir nicht zurückfallen. Es wird nicht eine Zeit geben, dass wir auf Drehwähler oder Morse Code zurückfallen wollen.
Oder Monopole. Telco Monopolis.
Wir müssen einfach für die Sachen, die wir haben wollen, wenn Hart auf Hart kommt, müssen wir uns einen sozialen Kreis aufbauen mit Leuten, die das dann auch können.
Und es wird die Sachen geben.
Und wir müssen auch selber damit beschäftigen. Nicht nur Leute suchen, die das können, sondern selber sich die Zeit nehmen, die Sachen zu lernen.
Und es wird eine Zeit geben, wo es einfach das passiert, was funktioniert. Und das heißt, wer ein funktionierendes Modell hat, sei es ein technisches Modell, sei es ein gesellschaftliches Modell.
Oder beides zusammen.
Oder beides zusammen. Wer ein funktionierendes Modell hat, wie die Welt aussehen könnte und das umsetzen kann, wird das Modell sein für viele andere Plätze, wo das genau das Gleiche passieren wird. In einer Zeit, wo sich alles ändert, sind die Leute, die was auf die Beine bekommen, haben die Macht.
Die, die zuerst was fertig haben, machen den Standard.
Wer Macht hat Recht.
Das ist ja eigentlich auch bei uns immer das Motto.
Genau. In diesem Sinne, vielen Dank fürs Zuhören. Vielen Dank an Rob fürs Teilnehmen.
Und ihr seid herzlich eingeladen, zum CCC-Kongress zu kommen, um euch die Sachen anzugucken. Versteht, wie das alles funktioniert. Das kann man alles verstehen.
Und solange diese Wirtschaft dort draußen noch funktioniert, könnt ihr auch noch auf den Flatter-Knopf drücken und uns ein wenig kapitalistische Wert anhand zu kommen lassen, solange die noch irgendwas wert sind. Und ansonsten vielen Dank fürs Zuhören und bis zum nächsten Mal.